une production du studio sf bio venus au
sans filtre présenté par qu'un semi le
podcast où on parle de ce qu'on veut que
nos invités date si tu cherches quentin
avec moi doom plantes
cette semaine on vous annonce notre
nouveau partenariat officiel avec 15 me
fait pour les prochains mois et vont
présenter tous nos podcasts et on va
voir un code promo pour vous qui vont
rouler 24 sur sept c'est le sans fil dhr
pour 20% de rabais sur tous les produits
qui en semi puis on vous parlait de
plusieurs de leurs langues de leurs
nouvelles collections dans les prochains
épisodes
sinon en ce moment sur notre page
pétrole
on a des podcasts en avance je vais vous
les nommez comme sonné comme une gang on
à simon coutu journaliste dany turcotte
que vous connaissez sylvain saint-amour
plus
ariel desjardins charbonneau qui sont
des physios qui va nous parler de
douleur je n'attends voir notre ami et
musiciens catherine fournet cassen
fournier dis-je femmes politiques
extraordinaires vincent vallières que
vous connaissez thomas levac et
stéphanie van laack co-animateur du
podcast qu'aux plus vert et file droit
avec qui on vient juste d'enregistrer
donc ce sont disponibles sur le pétrole
au moment où est-ce qu'on vous parle
fait que aller voir le lien est dans la
description du podcast sinon cette
semaine donne cette semaine un homme
présent de recevoir jean martin fortier
le jardiniers maraîchers lui-même un
gars qui veut révolutionner le monde et
l'agriculture
lang drivée par
ces idéaux ses convictions
environnementalistes c'est vraiment beau
de voir quelqu'un justement qui qui qui
avec ses mains puis avec la terre change
le monde l'enfant c'est quelqu'un qui
fait de l'agriculture bio l'agriculture
de proximité qui l'a promouvoit beaucoup
qui fait pousser des légumes sur un
hectare de table qui fait qu'ils
quittent tourner ça en business vraiment
florissante
c'était super intéressant moi ça m'a
vraiment ouvert les yeux intéressés à
l'agriculture sujet que je ne
connaissais pas et que j'avais je
pensais plus d'intérêt mais finalement
c'est vraiment inspirant de voir
quelqu'un qui vous si passionné par ce
qu'il fait - tout à fait un super
conversation juste avant d'aller
l'écouter on va aller remercier nos
commanditaires sans tout elle sans qu'
en tout ce ne serait possible fait que
mon pote tu fouilles
le podcast de semaine et présenté par m
me pour un ca si vous écoutez assidûment
le sans-fil podcast puis j'imagine que
si vous entendez ce que je dis en ce
moment c'est que vous faites partie de
ces gens là qui nous écoutent
vous savez que l'on commence à se
questionner sur qu'est ce qu'on fait
dans le futur est ce qu'on veut des
enfants est ce qu'on veut s'acheter une
maison éventuellement on est rendu à
stage qu'à cet âge là une décision qui
est aussi important d'enfants a poussé
prend une assurance vise pas le genre
d'affaires qu'on pense on dirait que
c'est tellement compliqué mais c'est
quand même important parce que touchons
du bois s'il ya quelque chose qui vous
arrive vous voulez pas laisser un
problème ou les blessés vous ou vos
proches en fait dans le trouble déjà
qu'ils vont avoir à dealé avec le deuil
chose qui est extrêmement difficile donc
emma point sur arrive avec la solution
d'une part et la conseillère les prix
sont vraiment raisonnable c'est super
facile et pas d'examen médical à faire
plus face aux en ligne safran
by minute benoît transpole ont eu aussi
de l'aide en ligne façon à puget en mode
chez vous c'est vraiment quelque chose
puis une fois que c'est réglé une fausse
et faisaient plus de tracas et
vous avez l'esprit tranquille une fois
que c'est réglé donc comme du ph quand
on devient adulte peine chose qui
quelque chose qu'il faut penser faut
passer la soirée et espèce d'homme le
mentionner au passage mais si vous
n'êtes pas certain de quelle assurance
c'est la bonne pour vous il ya des
techniciens qui vont vous aider
directement pour guider vers la
meilleure solution et merci beaucoup
aimé points 6 eur puis à lecce que ça
pour vrai faut y penser
le podcast de cette semaine et présenté
par le fournisseur officiel d'alcool du
studio sfg nommé hochelaga une
microbrasserie et distilleries
québécoise
on est extrêmement contents de notre
partenariat avec la schlague parce que
ça nous permet d'offrir les produits
lush lagat nous invitez vous venez ici
pas juste notre invité nos clients fait
tout le monde qui vient au studio qui
peuvent rentrer ici ouvrir le petit
frigo spagnou schlague c'est vraiment de
la bombe puis en plus des produits
extraordinaires j'ai goûté à la halle à
la bière la pomme grenade en fait une
saveur estivale vraiment bonne si vous
aimez sont un petit peu plus d'un qui
goûte e la doublette pied qui est une
évidence en 1h pied c'est extraordinaire
comme bien c'est fait que des
ingrédients pour la major la majorité de
gardiens en fait ces deux ingrédients
locaux puis donne tout en un coup de
coeur c'était moi cet été si les
ceintures c'est à la mode cet été
plusieurs compagnies essaient de semer
les meilleurs
si vraiment les slides pauvres il ya
trois savoir citron mangue et rhubarbe
c'est grave guava au bar pour sa soeur
c'est frais c'est pas trop sucré c'est
rafraîchissant c'est de l'eau pétillante
en fête alcoolisée avec un petit fond de
fruits c'est super quand il fait chaud
quand on est dehors qui fait beau
sa garde au frais sa garde de rater sa
garde par la sfef merci au flag pour
cette très belle collaboration puis
allez vous procurer les produits flag
partout procurer votre halton
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les bois bien merci d'être là le plaisir
j'adore votre set up c'est super cool si
c'est qu'un jour on s'échange facto à
des agriculteurs
ouais explique nous c'est quoi le type
d'agriculture que de fait képi mettons
puis en quoi ça se remarque tu mets ton
et culture qu'à ses coups de masse
conventionnelle convention demain ok
baignade moi j'ai plusieurs titres pour
me défendre je fais de l'agriculture de
proximité
c'est une espèce de buzz word à
comprendre moi dans le fond je perds une
ferme chez les légumes que je fais
pousser donc je vous parle on ferme
j'ai comme un gros gros jardin vivant
directement mes légumes à du monde comme
vous autres qui viennent le samedi matin
au marché ou à travers les paniers bio
d'abord nos paniers bio avancés avec
équiterre le sait avec un autre le
réseau des fermiers de famille du pam en
link down du moins à chaque semaine j'ai
eu une portée mais les gars qui en gros
là c'est pas mal ce qu'on sait c'est
qu'ils n'ont c'est vraiment simple dans
tout dans la proche dans le modèle puis
dans la proximité la relation après ça
mon travail
cette fois poussé 50 légumes différents
d'abord t'aider rigide culture pour
chaque légume de m'assurer que j'ai
toujours les meilleurs légumes toujours
les quantités qu'il faut au bon moment
il ya de la complexité non tout ça mais
ça c'est un agriculteur bio c'est du bio
évidemment fermiers de famille parce que
j'étais en vente directe parce que je
fais des paniers parce que je fais des
marchés puis les méthodes que moi j'ai
développés qui sont un peu encore dans
tout ce groupe ''le les agriculteurs
alternatif dont j'ai développé un peu
des techniques chez l'écriture sans
tracteur on aperçoit l'agriculture bio
intensive
le livre que j'ai écrit le jardinier
maraîchine décrivez
décrit toutes les étapes de comme en
face de l'église c'est comme un peu
l'agent de bip dû te ment d'agriculture
bio etc de ce que je disais ça a été
vendu plus de 5000 exemplaires traduit
dans cette langue
vraiment ça fait le tour de ce livre
listé comme devenu un benchmark qui
écoutent ses 200 milles dans 10 langues
les quatre jo bo de mousser ses affaires
mais 200 lycées du livre un tabac renard
ouais c'est beaucoup en c
c'est cool parce que tu quand j'ai écrit
ce livre là moi je teste vraiment nobody
j'avais fait ma micro ferme si dans le
fond notre came to find a fait un
hectare gains après le terrible vite tu
disais que c'est hector là était capable
de générer 200 mille dollars de revenus
dans dans le champ temps de dire ça dans
la série le plus que jamais au début
c'était 100 milles
quand on est sorti avec succès dans fast
and chips est ce qu'on me dit on faisait
120 milles devant ça c'est en vendant
directement au monde dans des marchés de
droits comme ce marché panier comme
celle des pc à l'épicerie
le message c'est devenu le mesclun de la
grelinette le la grelinette se nomme
affirme c'est devenu un peu la potion
magique lé tout le monde dans le village
achète son mesclun acquis qu'ils
feraient récolté deux fois par semaine
si l'on mange seul comme comme son
élevage qui mangent de l'herbe à titres
représentatifs sur une sur une ferme de
monoculture mettant de maïs 1 hector
représente 100 piasses 500 de l'or
tabarnak
comment explique moins commun deux bouts
à ton truc mais qu'est ce qui explique
cette différence la massive de rendement
il ya plein de choses métier la première
affaire c'est bon c'est quand on fait du
bien on fait du gringue et puis on fait
des légumes c'est pas la même affaire si
si je faisais du maïs sur un hectare mes
méthodes
pas sûr que je révise yves castrec enfin
même si le fait qu'on vend directement
ce qu'on produit ça c'est la clé
c'est qu'on a pas d'intermédiaire puis
on n'a pas de marge qui sont pris par le
distributeur par li missié c'est
vraiment de la vente directe donc ça
c'est c'est la grosse affaire puis quand
et pas dans mon modèle
dans le modèle classique donc tu te fais
des laitues les laitues et à l'épicerie
vival 2,50
toi tu as fait peut-être 45 sur ta
laitue l'ipsi a fait une pièce éveil et
puis le distributeur et fait 66 ans qui
fait tout pour faire de l'argent faut
que tu en fasses travail web la literie
pilote fait de l'argent sur ton volumes
plus tard en fait plus tu fais de
l'argent donc plus venant faire plus tu
affirmes est grosse plus tu es mécanisée
plutôt des travailleurs immigrants qui
vient de ramasser ça parce que tu étais
pas un
hector le témoin sans hector s'élève à
8,6 et tout un modèle c'est aussi
l'utilisation des pesticides sont je
veux exactement parce que tu es tu en
monoculture donc loti sol sont
fragilisés pilote appuie d'insectes fait
que là tu avais déséquilibre écologique
donc le cahier un insecte mauvais qui
arrive lui à toute la place parce que
c'est quand même un peu dans un désert
fait ça tout ça c'est pour rentrer dans
les chaînes de distribution
ça c'est le modèle des 60 dernières
années mais là ce qui s'est passé c'est
que ce modèle là finalement c'est on
voit qu'il ya plein de problèmes
puis les fermiers de famille
l'agriculture de proximité c'est la
réponse
moi je vais peut-être pas aller dans la
grande chaîne cherchait mallet dessus à
trois pièces que je sais pas bien d'où
je aller l'acheter chez jean marc train
il est et je sais de cavia je connais je
connais son intention de seïf et ça
parce qu'ils aiment ça pue il fait ça
parce qu'il sait qui me nourrit mes
enfants avec un souci envers ma part que
je suis environnementale pilat
cette formule là ce qui est magique
dedans c'est que ça moi j'ai pas besoin
de nourrir tout le monde
ce que je veux c'est qu'il ya une autre
firme comme la mienne puis un autre peu
non peuls ont fait un autre
quand j'ai écrit mon livre c'était ça
l'idée c'était de donner des clés aux
gens pour partir leur ferme
oui réussi un peu comme il en bosse dans
son brevet de sa tesla de nos brevets de
voici comment ça comment une bonne
technique pour ce faire une ferme de
familles laissées quoi écouter quand
même mais c'est moi moi j'avais trouvé
des techniques en fait parce que dans
l'agriculture que j'étais décrit le vous
ai décrit la plus classique fois des
volumes ça prend de la machinerie
ça prend des équipements sapant les
entrepôts ça prend un pétrole à gérer ça
prend c'est beaucoup de terre effective
pour un jeune qui commence c'est
beglitis et que c'est fait qu'il n'y a
pas beaucoup de jeunes depuis 40 ans qui
voulait faire ça parce que c'était comme
le step up était trop gros piti ils font
pas beaucoup d'argent dans le fond
effective doit beaucoup de stress
travail coûterait beaucoup d'argent
effectués depuis 40 ans tu avais de
moins en moins nombreux qu'il veut faire
le métier
pete applique des pesticides tout
plaquer mais là moi c'est sur un hectare
j'ai pas tracteur j'ai pas besoin
d'avoir des travailleurs migrants tout
le monde aime son travail est ce ma
ferme je gagne bien ma vie je rencontre
des gens qui me disent merci à chaque
semaine je fais de l'argent je fais du
cache cache aussi des palais en fait en
train de dire que c'est moins difficile
fait plus d'argent
thomas des contacts humains qui moment
il dit c'est le plus axée plus
accessible mais tout travail est-ce que
ce qui m'étonne journée de travail sur
ta ferme ça mais je les travaille sur
une ferme industrielle
ben non parce que tu nous autres on va
passer d'une tâche à l'autre on va
changer de tête cette faction différents
industriels tu peux passer le tracteur
d'un champ pendant une journée au
complot ou ramasser des choux pendant
une semaine
ouais donc quand tu te ramasses déchu
pendant deux semaines les gosses et
c'est arrive à 16h30
je suis ramos des shops et l'eau un
choix je ramasse des chevaux jusqu'à
11h30 tu ne poses de 40 minutes qui
continue jusqu'à 5 heures entre amos des
choux
le lendemain screenshot effectivement
donné on se dit pourquoi y ait plus
personne qui veut travailler d'un champ
mais des fois king louis fait les seuls
qui veulent faire ce vraiment qu'ils
sont motivés c'est les travailleurs
migrants guatémaltèque moi ça c'est du
bonbon le cacher jouer huit lits pour
eux sont comme moi je suis payé comme
cinq de leurs ceux qui viennent s'y font
un sacrifice mais ils sont bien payés
puissants cercles
ils sont comme sont pas ici pour tout
les restes sont visibles par l'argent de
sabadell le ton à quoi ces négatifs
parce que je sens qu'il ya quand même
mais une critique ne demandent pourquoi
met-on qu'est ce que tu vois de deux
mauvais la donne dans le modèle
classique dont le fils de que les
travailleurs étrangers qui viennent
sinon il rien de mal c'est aux autres
sont pas maltraitées tout contrairement
à ce qu'on pense le 10 août au québec
qui sont bien encadrés illicites et
c'est compliqué d'avoir des travailleurs
migrants il faut vraiment un bon
logement trop petit pas allé jusqu à les
animer le soir le cessonnais mais il ya
un encadrement ses autres viennent s'y
font de l'argent sont contents il n'y a
pas vraiment rien de mal avec ça la
seule affaire s excitent est une rivière
tu passes au bac ou c'était un cours
d'eau tu passes au bac c'est comme si on
se demande pourquoi toutes nos lacs et
nos rivières sont polluées bien un bon
coup qu'ils sont là c'est parce que ce
modèle agricole là il le fait que tu est
à une échelle gros comme ça peut-être en
monoculture tour ajoute des engrais
chimiques tu rajoutes des pesticides
puis tu fais des labos étaient dans des
gros volumes l'impact écologique c'est
que l'eau est contaminée
puis ça ça pour moi c'est la plus grosse
critique il ya un anagramme qui traite
tout le monde en parlait la semaine
dernière je croyais que j'imagine que tu
sais c'est qu'ils pourraient être qu
elle lui disait que on utilisait trop
beaucoup trop de d'engrais chimiques de
pesticides par le québec versus dans
notre place dans le monde dans ces
genres de deux grosses culture
l'industriel puis pourquoi on a une
suisse trop en fait conçu juste culturel
lui parler des lobbys ben oui si sur le
fond c'est que moi je n'utilise pas les
héros non c'est steve green j'utilisais
des biopesticides donc qu'elle sait
contrairement aux pesticides chimiques
synthétiques mois il va se photo
dégradés ou votre bio dégressive à
jamais coulé dans les cours d'eau jamais
d'algues bleues n'honore pas de ses
fesses à partir de course et c'est ben
écoute les miens ccc aussi les mêmes
compagnies sauf qu'ils partent à partir
des molécules naturelles
ils vont prendre une plante qu'ils vont
faire un extrait le cerveau de venir ça
va tuer ça va tuer des insectes parce
que c'est un poison avec une certaine
dose mais ça demande naturelle en disque
en agriculture conventionnelle
moi j'aime plus à appeler l'écriture
chimiques secte et 100 laboratoires y
ont développé des molécules chine à
partir du pétrole
donc il ya une chimie qui est fait pour
faire un poison puis j'imagine qu'ils
mettent dans les champs y moins cher
qu'un long qui la réponse à ta question
le pi louis aubert il le dit à tout le
monde en parle tout ça c'est la vérité
c'est juste pour tout déconstruire pour
bien comprendre ça des fois c'est
compliqué c'est que quand tu as des
pesticides avant quand tu as des engrais
avant tout en un
tu es donc fait de la promotion donc te
dis go sa route a donc déjà de recherche
donc tout un arsenal de marketing totti
si tu regardes dérivés agricoles apport
la mienne c'est rempli de pub de
pesticides de tracteurs septièmement de
neil les acteurs sont pas insensibles à
saulty ce qui le situe de la pub
orientées comme sur cette partie
non mais c'est salé depuis cinquante ans
et que dans le fond on avait quelque
chose à vendre
quant à lui vendu puis le moment donné
tu es qu'arrivait clip avec les engrais
et les pesticides c'est que quand tu en
mets ta pauvre iton sol et fait que
s'effectue donc j'ai dû utiliser ce
conte un service u17 vicieux le sitar
est dans la m c'est comme un peu une
zone lotie l'on boit du café se mettront
en bois pas mal plus tard est cependant
tout à fait mais là c'est comme trois
cadenas ter aa donne pas de rendement
fait que les agriculteurs sont pris dans
cet engrenage l'appui la réponse à ta
question c'est y avait un industrie
après la deuxième guerre mondiale
parce qu'ils y ont développé toutes les
industriels chimiques pour les armes se
sont recyclés là-dedans pis les
agriculteurs aujourd'hui son prix avec
ceux puis louis la base qui est venu
dire c'est pas juste les agriculteurs
c'est aussi les agronomes sont supposés
d'encadrer le militant qui sont trop
influencer de façon vraiment malsaines
par les vents du de pesticides les
vernis engrais qui sont avec eux c'est
monsanto ces grosses compagnies c'est
sûr avec ces mêmes peuples je tente en
déduire que je je
le voisin d'affaires qui était une
grosse culture comme ceux chimiques qui
shootait si on peut situer dans un avion
tourner le capteur part de son chant le
tice et comme les images les carcasses
et à l'épicerie pts achètes ton brocoli
pour sa part rien d'autre comme dans
apocalypse now avec l'hélicoptère qui
d'europe défaite et c'est ça c'est une
guerre c'est une guerre est une guerre à
l'écologie s'est fait que l'agriculture
chimique c'est de dire tout les
problèmes qu'on aurait on sent on veut
pas travailler que la nature on veut
juste s'en débarrasser puis c'est sûr je
vais pas tomber trop diplômés this c'est
un peu le paradoxe de notre société
aussi c'est dans les années 40 50 60
comme on est on s'est mis à manger du
fromage kraft
il ya eu comme pleine affaire comme
sauter lille et les lumières on voulait
pu leur donner le lait maternel on leur
disait faut que je prenne du lait en
poudre
c'est toute cette idée là de dire on va
remplacer la nature par quelque chose de
chimiques artificiel mais dans faust ou
du marketing parce qu'on veut demande du
racket c'est le bonhomme l'insee
s'appuie nous les fermiers de famille ce
qu'ont démontré que c'était pas besoin
de tout ça jean produit des légumes là
ça mais là lecteurs la personne qui m'a
cote tant qu'on y est ultra productif
on ira entame on est écologique on
pollue pas les cours d'eau
après ça la critique nous on nous fait
c'est oui mais oui mais si tu veux te
nourrit le québec avec ce geste ces
locations que canal est plausible c'est
sûr exil - mon projet de vie
tout ce que je fais c'est de dire car
moi je vois pas nourrir le québec je
veux honorer mon village
non mais je vais former dix mille ferme
qui peuvent honorer leur village puis
dans cinq ans ou dans dix ans dans quel
sens va se reparler le camp il va avoir
15 mille nouvelles fermes comme la
mienne
on verra ce que ça donne pis c'est ça
que je trouve qu'il est l'argument qui
trie peur de dire on veut pas nourrir le
monde on veut pas nourrir le québec on
veut nourrir le village on va avoir
plein de firmes comme les micro
brasserie tri on avait tous besoin de
bons films qui donnent la bière à toutes
les dépanneurs du québec où on est
content d'avoir pris une micro g après
un retour ça prend un retour massif à la
vie rurale quand même le défaut tel
intérêt pour les gens en ville les gens
qui ont touché pas où tu as grandi
métier je pense pas que saint bruno en
banlieue c'est cette grande banlieue
manitou l'appel de la terre ce mais je
me dis inversement il forcément il va
avoir une raison pourquoi il y aussi eu
un exode vers la ville à une certaine
époque pas si c'est pas une vie qui est
facile puisque pas pour tout le monde
non plus ben ça c'est vraiment un coup
qui est en parle parce que ce que moi
j'ai vécu la raison pourquoi moi je
tombais jeunes agriculteurs c'est que
quand j'ai fini moi j'ai étudié à mcgill
en écologie bien environnement qui est
j'ai rencontré ma blonde là bas la
pression on est parti puis on a voyagé
au mexique on est allé se fait et on est
allé travailler sur des cafés talent
puis on était vraiment dans un trip
granholm et sensibiliser à tout ça
magnifique table lors varidel moi ce
test est encore aujourd'hui je suis né à
tours a rejoint oui si on la connaît pas
directement
puis après sa lentille gégé et et
construire des maisons en tenue riscle
et au nouveau-mexique des richie du
super prestige et travailler sur une
ferme parce que je voulais faire ça et
comme comme si vous deviez moi je vais
aller très sûr de faire
tous étaient des driver par ta
conscience écologique unima montety dans
l'environnement j'ai étudié
l'environnement j'ai planté des arbres
bisig ramasser des champignons hugon
j'aime c'est dehors je fais du plein air
qui moi mes études à mcgill
j'étais en contact j'ai pour une espèce
de vague anglophone antimondialistes ou
est-ce que c'était comme on ressent un
plan question la mondialisation disais
que tu habites dans un an et demi avec
si on était si beau bien saint denis et
rachel en haut du gap
c'est un vin ennemis sont des deux gros
à barbe du collet ont été 10
moi ça m'a beaucoup influencé tous
surpris d'apprendre un peu sur
l'anarchisme pilati remettre le système
en question
intellectuellement ça me fit days
beaucoup mais là quand vous travaillez
sur un café talent avec des paysans
mexicains qui ont 60 65 ans qui savent
pas les épices et son bol c'est du beau
monde tu es contente une belle connexion
puis je vis après ça je travaille
richard des langes et au nouveau mexique
un gaspésien qu'il a beau loft story
shirt richaud
c'est le king la salade à santa fe santa
fe ces communes
c'est comme le malaise des états unis la
tige le monde et tous m'ont fait du yoga
autre monde mange bien tout le monde
c'était des anciens hippies c'est
vraiment une place puis participe à tous
de québec a fait date
je me tâte une petite ferme de la bonne
moi je connais pas pourquoi henry chance
c'était vraiment un personnage vraiment
intéressant lui justement quand j'étais
au nouveau mexique lui il faisait
c'était la grosse tête bush à l'époque
c'était la guerre du golfe lui avait
taillé ce n'est pas un cadre bien les
manifestants il y avait vraiment quelque
chose en lui le quitter que je me batte
antique on forme un champ d'action
mais richard y avait aussi pas light
star comme lui il y avait une belle
ferme qu'ils louent et puis il ya les au
marché de santa fé in samedi piste et
grohl marche et un taf il y avait
peut-être 30-40 vendeur d'un gros
happening plus le monde faisait la ligne
pour sa salade puis tout le monde le
remercier si moi je faisais la crise
puis je voyais
cash qui faisait les billets de 20 et
seulement deux mondes payant cash s'est
fini comme 3000 billets de 20 et l'opt
et moi j'ai 20 21 h jusqu'à 16 ans les
légumes c'est avoir une place moi ça me
prenait pas une et aimer ce talent là
tic en quantité pays 14,15 dollars ptt
déduction puis tout s'est finalement
taux d'échec de 300 pièces par semaine
puis l'hiver il partait au mexique était
là c'était cool on était dans le champ
pitié le formule m'inquiète toutes nos
amis ça donnait des fermiers c'était
vraiment vraiment vraiment aux questions
qu'il louait sa terre spoliée qu'il
exploitait dans le fond non mais c'est à
dire riche propriétaire qui avait des
petites landes qui lui a loué
qu'effectivement moi j'ai commencé en
agriculture avec ça c'est toujours un
modèle point mon premier contact le
tiche avait rien d'autre que je sais ce
pas positif c'était cool snif payeur ça
avait du sens aussi parce que je voyais
aussi que le légume que tu produis que
tu vend directement affirme une boucle
n'est pas dans le système mondialisé du
fait du bien c'est l'écologie fait qu on
y est on y restait deux enveloppes une
impression du revenu québec parce que tu
voulais vivre au québec
ouais puis là je vais faire la bvk avec
la vie à graal c'est que quand on y re
venu c'était pas comme on ouvre au
mexique ce permis était pas célébrer pis
si tu avais pas les cafés fermiers comme
on a fait les bugs aujourd'hui que tu
avais pas tout la vibe mais moi je
l'avais vu se savait que ça existait et
par maman moi ce n'est pas si je me
disais c'est sûr que ça s'en vient c'est
sûr sûr sûr ça s'en vient pilot c'est
arrivé aujourd'hui je vis là dedans
c'est moi mon village à felsberg
quand j'ai commencé avec deux fermes bio
le y en a 30
si on a les mercredis fermiers ou est ce
que tu es tout le village j'aime bien
les gens qui travaillent sur les fermes
c'est une gagnons des parts et régions
est ce que est ce qu'il ya une relation
cause à effet de touax installe le
clairement sa forme et du monde ou c'est
juste un mouvement qui tu étais un parmi
plusieurs qui ont eu la même idée même
temps maintenant je suis parmi plusieurs
qui a eu
des en même temps et j'ai propulser le
mouvement même pas mon travail dans mon
livre par les gens que j'ai formés à la
ferme avec maude hélène qui peu après ça
parce que moi mon modèle ils étaient
gagnants il permettait de démarrer
rapidement pouvoir dissous vite fait
tout les gens que j'ai formés qui ont
réussi c'est devenu un peu un template
un moment donné que d'autres ont suivi
puis la salle es aimé essaimé clauzel
aujourd'hui c'est dans 65 pays le tg
dgdi genesis et pas des disciples de moi
gourou et dj déjà cuits une technique
puis method man j'enseigne un cours en
ligne jeux documente tout c'est le
détail de chaque affaire fait que c'est
un mélange des deux pour te répondre
dans ce que tu viens de dire
il ya un point qui m'apparaît comme
important étant celui de la rentabilité
rapide parce que j'imagine que ça prend
quand même un bon un bon fronte pour ce
stark these mettons je sais pas comment
ça peut coûter une terre une ferme puis
1 hector ou deux ou trois hauts cadres
sais pas comment ça peut coûter mais
probablement que quelqu'un qui sort de
meggie l'environnement qui se dit moss
et ça je le faire faut que ce soit faut
qu'ils soient capables de se rembourser
parce qu'il a ramené j'imagine c'est un
investissement qui considérable mais là
il ya deux problèmes
ce que ça soulève c'est que c'est moi
j'ai besoin d'un hectare mais en ce
moment on a des lois de zonage agricole
au québec qui permet pas de trouver 5 ha
site monash tessin où 36 essais erreurs
que tu vas trouver 30 hectares fait que
les modèles il est encore pour des
productions qu'elles occasionnellement
conventionnelle pilotis ce si long avant
de se déconstruire ça parce qu'en même
temps on a une loi qui protège les
terres agricoles con comme la
spéculation contre le développement
urbain qu'en est il il ya plein de
bonnes raisons pour que tous devront
zonage agricole
sauf que quand et un maraîcher comme moi
se cherche 2 3 4 5 10 août et des
acteurs rêveur c'est impossible ou serra
parce que la loi ne permet pas de
morceler fx haye comme un gros enjeu là
dessus
mais oui c'est petit mais tu ne gagnes
puis a acheté 1 100 hectares à granby
les projets de gagner c'est toujours le
fun au début ça vient de la complexité
mais ça c'est un des gros freins mais
plus on est à faire ce métier là c'est
pour te supporter c'est aussi des
équipements et outils les chances au
québec parce que quand et un agriculteur
petit démarre un projet de ferme tous le
droit à une prime à l'établissement qui
me mauger reçu trente mille python
terrain tu affirmes de coûter combien
baie comeau j'ai acheté à felsberg un
clapies donc c'est un ancien bâtiment où
il y avait des latins
c'était quatre hectares j'ai payé cent
mille fait que t'es même pas une forme
la base tout mon modèle à moi enigma
contraintes d'espacé qui j'avais 4 ha
j'ai trop en beau que je que je voulais
pas coupé c'est une érablière puis fait
que j'avais un hector puis au milieu de
ça il y avait un clapier qui faisait sa
part 40 que j'ai divisé en deux j'ai
construit ma maison dans une partie
c'est d'ailleurs c'était quand même une
grosse bâtisse comme ici le léger frais
mais des planches et des plafonds se
fait une maison mais ma contraintes de
terrain c'est que j'avais un hector avec
moi j'ai voulu la rentabiliser la
maximiser développer des techniques pour
toujours faire plus de légumes plus de
légumes sur un hectare
c'est ça qui a créé mon modèle que manca
mandat de huit ans petit fils alors
c'est un peu à faire des choix qui t'ont
amené vers la méthode du tout et c'est
pour ça que j'ai pas tracteur parce
qu'un tracteur et finalement il prend 20
de la place luc en ituri qui tourne au
bout du rêve peut pas avoir des carottes
l'autre des trois secteurs - tout chaque
match car il était temps légumes ça et
rita
je travaille des outils manuels si
j'avais voyagé à cuba j'avais vu des
trucs la boj avait en france j'avais vu
des trucs là bas en californie fait que
j'ai tout ramené ça ici puis on a mis
tout en place un système qui vraiment
super performant mais exit manuel qui
coûte pas cher
fake pour répondre à la question tantôt
c'est les jeunes qui sortent de mégille
sont pas besoin d'être propriétaires ils
peuvent louer et à répartir une business
se montrent et dessert
puis là après 2,3 à lyon un petit mise
de fonds ils ont un business qu'est cela
ils peuvent à lalbenque des écoutes moi
je vais acheter une terre je vais
acheter une maison est foutu le fasse
par étapes avec mais le modèle que moi
je moi j'fais permettant même un toit un
conteneur sur un demi siècle où un demi
hectare
puis les gars offert l'argent sur ce
tournoi qui fait comme et de légumes
différents tu fais tu y mets ton combien
de récolte dans une saison de plus fort
moi je vais faire deux à trois légumes
par on a tout dit viser lecteurs en
planches comme on a dit bloc des
planches trop faire des successions donc
tu utilises mettons que ça que lui en ce
moment je ramasse et des radis que j'ai
semé japon au début mars
je vais aller ramasser après ce jeu
c'est le même jour je vois transplanter
des laitues et les led suivons 1,40 jo
puis après ce jour là des haricots etc
si je veux avoir dans une même planche
trois légumes puis mais espacement de
culture mes haricots sont vraiment serré
parce que avec un tracteur quantifier
pour désherber tu as besoin de laisser
ben de la place entre chaque rame pour
que l'outil pas ou ce niveau si on est
rodé avec fait croit comprendre moi
insiste effectifs etc tout est
dimensionnée pour que ton tracteur
circulent avec téhéran sont loin tandis
que moi maintenant au luc avoir trop
orange carotte comme sage et j'en ai
cinq ici parce que j'ai pas besoin
d'aller sa clique un tracteur fait non
seulement je fais 2 3 les trois légumes
différents par blanche mais migrants
sont cinq fois plus serrés fait que sur
un acteur mais dans le fond je produis
comme si j'étais sur 10 puis il ya bien
des bennes et des bénéfices issus des
bénéfices à face au même titre des coûts
de production moins des plus efficaces
dans tes gestes d'anti mouvement fait
que chaque saison puis
trente autres tu disais maintenant à
place d'aller prendre mal et tu as trois
pièces à l'épicerie je vais aller
l'acheter une ferme de famille sk va
être à trois pièces aux silhouettes à
trois pièces c'est juste que l'action va
être plus complexe parce qu'il met au
moins nous autres on a un appart à
verdun puis mettons que je veux sur
sarthe soit le panier bio j'imagine qui
lui est ce qui te revient mais enfin je
m'en allais en une question de suite là
mais fait cette option là où une option
marché ouais puisque tu sembles dire
aussi c'est dans le marché de même
posture de la provenance de
l'approvisionnement de des sauces ça
dépend quel marché que comme le taux de
spams spécifiquement de jean talon parce
que moi c'est ce serait l'objet si
jamais si j'avais aléas place d'aller à
mon régime parce que les prix proche de
chez nous le sommes malheureusement bel
malheureusement et heureusement parce
que là c'est en train de changer depuis
cette année il ya vraiment eu beaucoup
de travail qui a été fait c'est quand
allez je vais te parler de jean talon
parce que c'est les mêmes organisateurs
ok mais à toi turgis propos mais juste à
jean talon moi avec mes légumes ni
samedi puis le dimanche la ferme des 80
faites moi quand j'étais à lille a pour
la première fois tout comme jean talon
et atwater
c'est vraiment cool des fjords c'est à
montréal
sauf que quand arrive le tout les étals
qui sont là il y en a même pas la moitié
des producteurs c'est tout des gens qui
vont au marché central chercher leurs
légumes le matin qui amène selon qu'il
est vivant et qu'il est que la personne
à qui tu veux que tu veux dire merci
pour ma peau elle qui fait c'est sur le
sépare des produits c'est sur ses pas et
alpi la face on s'est organisé tout sait
pas trop si tu penses que c'est des
cultivateurs et ayons tout écrit c'est
le local puis il ya des bananes gratte
un peu quand tu connais cet étudiant je
regarde des ombres domaine
ce serait trop facile raconte finalement
cédé devant moi ce que je trouve est
déplorable à l'époque c'est que tout le
monde allait à jean talon et atwater
ziza j'encourage la culture du québec ce
qui était vrai parce que c'est vrai que
c'est des produits du québec mais tanga
t'encourage pour la manne ferme qui t'a
pas vraiment un lien parce que c'est
tout les mêmes légumes ils vont tout au
marché central chercher les mêmes qu'à
la fecq
c'est s'était pas à ça que ça sert un
marché fermier un marché fermier c'est
pour donner un espace de vente à des
producteurs pour vendre leurs produits
directement sans passer par les
épiceries fake
ça a été long puis moi j'aimais ça a été
un microbot de médecins en lumière c'est
quand tu venais à mon kiosque
tu voyais on avait une grosse pancarte
vous êtes toutes nos légumes viennent de
notre ferme
si c'est comme exceptionnel de voir ça à
montréal mais si on avait été à toronto
à seattle à new york
s'agissant sari jamais existé ce parce
que ça aurait fait le new york times
puis s'arrête au scandale parce que le
farmers market une institution qui quand
même bien établis tels ou formules moins
que les gens vont là par solidarité
parce qu'ils veulent offrir
ils veulent encourager l'écriture locale
puis ils veulent ils veulent quelque
chose de vrai peu de temps ces pétitions
leur miroir quelque chose qui est pas ça
s'était mal mais là ça s'est vraiment
clarifiée il ya beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de gens qui sont partis de
jean-talon probablement trois autres des
gens qui étaient là depuis 40 ans un
vieux c'est un peu un peu mieux
puis là ils font de la place pour des
jeunes qui vont vendre des légumes
directement impliqués antibalas
jean-talon la lotus va vraiment acheté
d'un producteur qui veulent encourager
tous ces coups puis mettons que l'on
établit que mettons le prix est le même
je peux je comprends mais tombent dans
les villages c'est plus simple comme
façon de fonctionner ou est-ce qu'à
chaque je suppose et quand tu peux aller
à la ferme comme tels ou dans 1
je m'inquiète chemin puis acheter tes
trucs quand arrive dans une ville ou une
métropole comme au real si quoi le
modèle dont c'est parce qu'on peut on
peut penser si tu disais tantôt et je
veux pas nourrir le québec mais
optimalement moi j'aime sa pensée en
utopie pas mal tout le talent dans mes
décisions tout j'aime pas ça me dire
mettons voici mon modèle mais qui est
pas applicable
moi je voudrais s'imaginer ou du moins
qu'on essaye tout le monde
collectivement d'imaginer les méthodes
pas seulement pour l'agriculture mais
mettons je demande pour
l'électrification des transports ces
choses là où est-ce qu'on peut inclure
tout le monde dans le truc parce c'est
un modèle attelage c'est que c'est quoi
mettons dans une salle métropole de
lausanne et remettons les fermes lufa
ici qui sont sur les toits qui
permettent de fournir au dessus dans
cette direction là c'est utile c'est
quoi j'adore ta question
c'est vraiment pertinente et je vais te
répondre en deux temps la première
affaire c'est que ce que toi tu est en
train d'écrire là peut-être sans le
savoir c'est qu'il faut décentraliser
les solutions si tu veux que les gens
participent
il faut que tout le monde participe donc
quand on parle d'électrifier les
transports c'est peut-être un mauvais
exemple parce qu'au québec on à
l'hydroélectricité mais quand ils vont
ailleurs aux états unis ça veut dire que
tu vas en avant des panneaux solaires ça
veut dire que tu vas récupérer ton dos
ça veut dire que tu les éoliennes
devront pas tomber des aliens régionales
cissé quant au lieu de l'aider dire on a
un gros mastodontes de systèmes qui
nourrit tout le monde ça c'est le futur
de l'écologie parce que dans l'écologie
tout fonctionne par partout elles sont
selon moi ce que tu es dans tout les
facteurs l'aspect plurifactoriels de ton
endroit où est ce que tu vis avec toi tu
sais que ça c'est la big picture le smap
et je sais que tout est à verdun toi tu
veux encourager la culture locale mais
là il
c'est sûr qu'un farmers market à verdun
puis atwater classe et atwater les
autres ils font sûr que c'est juste des
fermiers locaux tôt quand tu vas acheter
leur tête en confiance aux autres qui
ont fait le travail instrus de trouver
les bonnes personnes et assuré que ce
que tu achètes cccc authentique
la pression est abonné à un panier nous
nous rangerons livre les jeudis au parc
georges étienne cartier avec la
grelinette pitié de 3,5 qui vient
chercher son panier de légumes pilote
sur un panier coutterand piastres
peut-être 45 pièces de légumes mandat je
les choisis juste pas mais on a des
formules maintenant tu peux les choisit
llosa est maintenant moi je cuisine
beaucoup fait que georges se serait
jointe une option en mettant deux mois
les légumes de la saison puis je fais ce
que je m'arrange avec le tue il ya plein
centre et tout faire dans le fond on est
en train ce qui est en train de se
passer c'est qu'il ya tellement de
d'engouement pour manger du local puis
des fermiers de famille que l'on est en
train de mettre la technologie là dedans
pour que tu as des boutiques en ligne
puisque l'auto tu peux choisir ce que tu
veux puis on va te monte des commandes
sont en train de se faire outre un
panier plus classique c'est comme ton
fond dont font garder ton fond de frigo
dans le fond c'est ce qu'ils mangent
toutes sortes vont être en santé
le tu peux aller à droite à rechercher
leur s ou tu peux aller aussi peut-être
une autre europe qui a des produits
locaux pilote quand tu veux manger au
resto bar à salades à vient de se
trouver dans un resto que le chef lui
achètent la vie locale
c'est finalement abandonné ton ton
environnement complet peut devenir bio
local penser parce que c'est tout en
train de se construire mais toi quand tu
achètes tu encourages sur l'impact c'est
c'est très considérable 10 juin cliente
plus ce genre de business le cdb puisque
ça vous êtes parce que moi mettons cette
idée là cindy qui me plaît énormément
mais je pense maintenant je pense juste
à mon quotidien puis après fille
j'imagine qu'il ya beaucoup de monde qui
pensait à ce à dire je veux juste ce
soit le plus simple possible parce que
moi mettons le au leur one stop shop
d'aller originaux de tout poignet en une
fois ça me prend 30 minutes dans ma
semaine puis j'ai tout ce qu'il me faut
c'est quand même attirance eu comme idée
mais je sais pas ouais ouais moi je te
challenge là dessus parce que quand ça
puis d'aller dans un marché fermier
parlent et ils cherchent et et légumes
allaient chez le boulanger qui fait du
bon pain et autres mangent pas de viande
mais là les chutes ont bouché que tu
sais qui fait vraiment bon job il salué
si tu commences à avoir plein d'amis
c'est le boucher c'est ton ami le
boulanger c'est ton ami le fermier de
famille c'est ton ami ya de quoi
vraiment nourrissant là dedans qui campe
une photo goutta seul d'aller dans le
one stop shop que tu sais que la viande
ces industriels tu voudrais jamais
manger cet avis désastreux le pain ok
les légumes c'est douteux c'est là que
tu remets un peu ça c'est si les epci
était plus des marchés fermés ce serait
cool mais présentement cc polke mais
c'est sûr c'est sûr je te qu'avec toi ce
que c'est plus attirant plus préfère
abso mais mettons pour quelqu'un ayant
une position j'ai pas la mère de famille
qui là bas c'est quand même
l'investissement tant droit de dire je
vais aller à plusieurs endroits
différents chercher chercher mon pain
chez boulanger je suis la viande chez le
boucher entretenir ses relations le
aller au marché tpiy qui a les plus
régulièrement c'est quand même pour
quelqu'un qui a pas le luxe d'avoir ce
temps le à donner il épicerie encore une
fois c'est à mouthe bon modèle mais vous
qu'on parle du teil commun qu'il faut
ralentir puis je disais on vient livre
la pandémie les gens ont du temps dans
le fond si c'est quand même prenez le
temps d'y aller ce moment c'est juste je
leur dirai c'est comme s'entraîner ici
ce soir pendant une heure par jour pour
colorer
je ne sais pas tout le monde qui est
sommé par là quelqu'un qui court à tous
les jours il va directement quant au gel
dans le top 5
enfin je voudrais jamais faire assassin
tiré fake mais je comprends les gaules
que l'épicerie tout le monde c'est là
c'est juste que dans ma tête à moi je me
dis c'est pas parce que c'est le même
qu'on pourrait pas faire mieux ou
autrement
puis il ya beaucoup de noms qu'ils font
des jeux qui voit là puis mais en fait
moi c'est l'option des paniers un mois
dans ma tête ça revenait plus cher que
non mais si ça revient pas que ça c'est
vraiment un choix définitif parce que ça
limite ça me fait chier de me déplacer à
chaque semaine pour mes légumes alors
qui mettons que j'ai je stack des
légumineuses dans mon garde manger la
seule chose qui manque à chaque semaine
ses délégués sinon je pourrai une pale
ale et puisqu'il met on parlera
longtemps pendant longtemps ce contexte
c'est sûr que c'est sûr que je vais dans
ma tête pour une conception du junior
jeu des sources de prononcer moins cher
parce que dans le fond dans le concept
des paniers et mettons que du péché pas
trente pièces de légumes tu vas avoir à
peu près 15 % 15 mai pour ça c'est pas
hors des extraits hausse parce que dans
le fond les bannis ce qui est cool c'est
que tout le monde prie paye mais ces six
mois j'ai sans famille qui m'ont payé 5
100 piasses mais j'ai cinquante mille
pièces dans mon compte de banque avant
que ma saison comme en moins mais en
échange je te donne un dire qu'à chaque
semaine je te ligue du bon stock mais
tout sera moss compagne et puis c'est
comme chez 17 enfants de ces temps ces
exemples-là puis celle hop tu sais que
tout ça c'est bon pour toi peut
apprécier si toi tu as envie de faire
quelque chose de plus une recette la
glotte qui va chercher ce qui te manque
mais au moins tu de ton frigo il est
plein de bon sens moi je pense c'est
simple
mais qu est ce que ça me parle beaucoup
ce que tu dis le jeu reste de check et
ce définitivement
l'autre question que j'ai parmi
plusieurs questions que j'ai mais
j'avais collaboré avec iga pour
s'éterniser dans le nord-est au
nord-ouest de l'île qui était qui avait
un jardin sur le toit
oui j'ai eu du chemin le chemin il
vendait ce qui faisait pousser en eau en
bout avec un espace dans les iga ou
est-ce que là c'est ça c'est les légumes
qu'on a fait c'est quoi ça ça c'est que
les gens peuvent guglia du chemin des
légumes sur le toit ils vont voir on
avait fait une capsule c'est un jardin
maraîcher qui s'inspire de mes
techniques une méthode que tu avais
travaillé là dessus j'ai pas travailler
là dessus mais celui qui le fait
il ya travaillé avec moi pendant pendant
une année
parce qu'il y avait un gars qui a jeté
aller on avait quand même fait un genre
de pique nique sur le toit le goya
voleurs de serment l'huile avec thème y
avait jean un chapeau loi je le vois tu
j'étais avec le propriétaire de cglu ya
justement prenantes à faire mais ça
c'est être hyper parce que dans le fond
c'est vrai c'est que ces authentiques
c'est moi c'est pas une spl magot et
lisbonne gymnich de pirogues
c'est sûr que si jamais le disait que
c'est tout les légumes bio viennent des
toiles sur pastore c'est juste une mini
fraction il y avait quand même bonne
section puis avait plusieurs options
dans le
c'est très qu ils ont même une caméra en
eau ou est ce qu'elle est et en bob tu
peux voir qu'est ce qui se passe à autre
mais ça séduit par local c'est super le
fun cette femme libre est plus qu comme
nos besoins puis ça c'est trippant mais
comme je te dis encore là pour rené
l'attend aussi c'est comme cette
solution le et pas globale non non non
non il parle à calmer ses multiples il
apparaît toutes les épiceries c'est si
chaque mois ou chaque groupe building de
mammouths il ya tellement de comme ça
qu'il faut le voir dit il faut le voir
que chaque initiative quand on est
ensemble ça remplace un gros système qui
est qui est brisée qui fait mal surtout
on y arriverait à nourrir tout le monde
si elle est assise une cette île comme
ceux de 96 comme son compère le pas
longtemps et vainement il me les petits
les populations ça a changé quand même
je dois le contexte a changé quand même
le théier beaucoup plus de gens vivent
maintenant il n'y aurait pas de suspense
ben écoute moi je me technique puisque
je fais je m'inspire beaucoup de comment
c'était à paris puis en france dans les
années 1800 1900 débuts jusqu'aux
jusqu'aux années car pendant 200 ans la
ville de paris elle a été nourrie par
des jardiniers maraîchers comme moi qui
faisais jean 8 culture par année moi je
t'ai dit de lui en faisait trop le jour
j en faisais 8 dans un climat plus doux
mais quand même il a été en périphérie
de paris et en pense un tueur de paris
puis il y avait des dizaines de milliers
de fermes qui rentrait deux fois par
semaine à paris dans des étals vendre
leurs légumes vendre un produit qui le
liera mancelle fumier parce que dans ces
instants là c'était tout en calèche bien
je vous les ramenez le fumier dans leur
jardin
c'est comme ça que le fumier sortait de
la ville puis il rentre et des légumes
c'était tout des acteurs deux acteurs
max puis ça nous aussi une ville de
quatre millions d'habitants
c'est paris le jeudi
on sait paris c'est une ville moderne
depuis longtemps on en serait à paris de
l'osce antal on aurait dû fan-boy
découvrable à paris 150 atari le ça se
passe il assistait les restaurants puis
tout pareil avec moi dans le fond quand
je lis ça puis je regarde ça je me dis
c'est pas c'est pas impossible de penser
qu'une ville peut-être t montréal c'est
quand même une métropole mais c'est une
ville comme sherbrooke nouvelles
combines comme vraiment de vitry plein
de villes qui pourraient être vraiment
plus s'approvisionner localement puis
voilà qu'est ce qui s'est passé pourquoi
qu'en italie notre chemin le t2
on sait tout sur spécialisé j'imagine
aussi été moins en moins de monde de
plus en plus de personnes vivent au
départ de moins en moins grand nombre de
personnes ce qui fait qu'il faut
produire de masse aussi pis on importe
plus mythiques
comment ça se fait qu'on a cru que c'est
une bonne idée d'aller dans cette
direction mais finalement on se rend
compte aujourd'hui que peut-être pour
mater jouer à la brasserie hochelaga
sont vos partenaires
cécile est propriétaire de la brasserie
t é 6 pts alors demandé comment ça qu'on
buvait tout le monde se tait de
l'abattre sans exception n'y avait rien
d'autre que ce partout ça serait quoi la
réponse c'est ça serait du genre ah
parce que les gens oublient c'est quoi
le goût de la bonne bière ou ce serait
plutôt d'un homme ayant pris les marchés
ils ont ils ont consolidé ils ont
consolidé ils ont consolidé le moment
donné ils ont tout piqué out les tipis
lyon panier le marché qui ont en fait
que beaucoup de choses en business ou
dans la vie ça se consoler de sa se
consolide sa se consolide sa se
consolident pire moment donné ça devient
une grosse affaire
pis le but c'est tout déconstruire ces
les médias bell pendant longtemps il y
avait belle il y avait vis des autres on
s'était tous leurs différends tripler
les petits joueurs le sud ils y font des
podcasts rioux douvres
last ranker du contenu alternatif s'est
passé mais c'est ça qui est avec les
légumes probablement sait comment donner
c'était toujours les épiceries sont
devenus de plus en plus grosses les
autres il voulait avoir un
l'intervenante une grosse ferme qui la
ramène 10000 à l'entrepôt où ils veulent
plein de voix qui amène se justifie le
hir distribution des classes est
toujours fort à faire et des plus gros
des plus gros fait que le fermier la
marée chez hachette l'autre qui achète
le château consolide sa se consolide
puis mona là on arrive avec un système
qui s'inhale en californie voir les
firmes de légumes le même le bio le rôle
pendant 1 heure et demie dans les champs
de brocoli pour l'autoroute on ne sort
au québec ce l'agriculture bio par
rapport à un non non on est vraiment on
est pionnier - pitt il loge doucement
californie faire des formations montrer
aux gens comment travailler et puis si à
cause d'eux les ressources qu'on est au
québec puis à cause conditions
il ya des avantages à être à payer 50%
tripous j'imagine puis à être un peu
plus socialiste c'est comme je le disais
le ciment qui sont mis en agriculture
qui est beaucoup de fermiers alternatif
qui en ont profité de ce site soit
courage et mettons tout faire davantage
ce fermier bio alternatif est ce que le
gouvernement encourage suis en ce moment
où le langage change déjà c'est bon
c'est gelé des subventions métis si vous
aviez le le ministre l'agriculture
réussi à votre podcast dit connaître
d'aussi et qu'apam en parlait il ya
visité ces fermes le tig est au courant
qui est en train de changer un peu la
culture
mais les gouvernements ces lots sur des
changements qui sont leur bateau a
rejoué mais tu dis le bio six pieds des
gentils que le louis robach soit tout le
monde en parle c'est le monsieur cible
avait coûté il était super authentique
ce n'était pas un révolutionnaire
mais ce qu'ils disent est vrai tellement
donné il faut se dire les vraies choses
je pense que je pense les québécois sont
prêtes aussi à bouger un peu là moi je
les ai vus à travers
ce soit mes émissions télé ou à révéler
les gens entendent parler de révolution
agricole puis son corps point là tu
parle souvent aussi de consommer de
cultiver y consommer les légumes fruits
et légumes de saisons en saisons chez
pika qu'on le regarde sous le prisme de
l'environnement pile l'achat local puis
tout se ça fait tout le sens du monde
mais mettons mettons j'imagine ses
premiers parents ce genre de demandes
mais prend le maquis inquiéter jeunes
des bananes à l'épicerie des kiwis de
paix d'amour c'est un luxe devrait pas
en avoir souvent pays où doivent juste
pour n'avoir pu amener ces choses sont
arrivées et puis on s'est mis à
découvrir des nouveaux aliments
parlement qui élit québécois jusqu'à 2
avait jamais mangé une piste ce juste du
point de vue de j'avais pas cette option
depuis maintenant sept options existent
c'est un progrès pleut je mets des
guillemets pour tous points de vue du
consommateur et il n'y avait pas de
bananes qui mène en journée le comment
aujourd'hui essayer de faire avaler
cette pilule aux gens déjà ben c'est
peut-être pas nécessaire d'avoir des
bananes en janvier puis d'avoir des
phrases tout le temps à longueur d'année
comment commencer de faire voir ce aux
gens comme un progrès ça c'est une bonne
question
c'est là moi moi ma réponse associative
dans le fond quand tu décides de manger
tous les balances d'instinct moyens
exemple parce que des balances des
bananes ça se remplace poppy si tu peux
pas dire aux gens manger des pommes ont
lu des bananes des tos balles et neuf
hommes jusqu'à paris c'est comme banales
tellement singulier comme comme fruité
mais mettons ton poivron rouge
monique et août est vraiment besoin de
cuisine et des poivrons rouges en
janvier février mars
quand tu pourrais sait utiliser faire
des recettes avec d'autres choses comme
quoi mettons paix maintenant qu'est ce
qui est tu disais janvier février mars
le succès quoique en mangeant les
foulées décembre janvier février mars
c'est les gros mois le débat
dans le fond la diète original classique
contemporaine c'est de toutes les
époques c'est de manger des légumes de
caveaux donc si tu vas avoir des
carottes
tu dois avoir des traces tu vas avoir
des pommes de terre parce qu ils se
conservent pas ce qui concerne ces sons
sont récoltés à l'automne sont mis dans
des caveaux le desa au fur et à mesure
ces sombres sont frais sont remplies de
vitamines sont encore bons sauf qui
concerne un petit après sur la liste est
longue et rutabagas céleri rave re a dit
dahico jeudi la liste est vrai qu au
moins 30 légumes qu'on peut manger en
saison mais faut se les cuisines c'est
là que c'est là je m'en aller j'imagine
que ce ça passe par ray enseigner la
cuisine oui apprendre à cuisiner
moi j'ai eu la chance dans ma vie deux
dates élevé même ma mère m'a toujours
intéressé à la cuisine puis je cuisinais
une à deux fois par semaine chez nous
pour la famille au complet puis j'ai
quand même appris ce qu'est ce que le
tue mais n'importe quoi puis je vois
capable de faire quelque chose avec thé
mais ça c'est vraiment pas tout le monde
cette opportunité là pour que
l'éducation à faire parce que moi
méthode humaine en situation et mettons
le je repense au panier que je parlais
tantôt il plus je pense plus je pense
que je sais ce que je vais faire le
coach pour mieux pour les nouveaux
clients
puis mais moi mettons ces paniers là
c'est ça m'attire beaucoup parce que je
sais que si je mens commandes à l'année
longue
ce que je vais recevoir je vais je vais
être capable de faire quelque chose avec
ça va jamais de perdu mes ongles
ouais mais mettons chez mettons pour toi
tu commandes un panier comme ça ça va
mourir dans le fond du frigo le tissu
j'imagine qu'il ya aussi et comment
conques ont suivi les deux mois il ya
beaucoup d'éducation à faire puis meetic
arrondi éducation c'est comme si comme
un drôle de mortiers c'est apprendre
c'est plus seulement 6 comme tout pour
toi si tu cuisines pas beaucoup
peut-être que tantôt la cuisine a
ordonné ta passion le petit bob capote
est riche
j'étais musicien peut-être des intérêts
différents mais il ya quelque chose de
vraiment important dans l'acte cuisine
et toi tu aimes sa cuisine et moi
j'adore sa cuisine et moi quand je
cuisine je me détends générer quelque
chose s'est passé c'est un bon moment
dans ma vie affective d'apprendre à
cuisiner des légumes différents pour moi
c'est le fun pour quelqu'un qui
peut-être qu'un aura de sept à cinq de
banlieue avec un nombre de trafics les
matins un an l'après midi qui arrive le
soir brûlé bénédicte est hissé la pizza
congelée dans le faux ok mais tu es
peut-être change ton lifestyle aussi
parce que dans le fond manger cuisine
c'est vraiment important puisqu'on est
dans nos cordes si si c'est vraiment
important
fake comment cette transition le boss
faire je sais pas mais oui les
l'éducation les chefs ou si c'est comme
nous tenons tout de grands chefs au
québec le tout les restaurants très peu
à montréal et cuisine tout en saison il
sans exception parce que pour eux c'est
juste comme ça que c'est ça c'est fait
que les autres ils sont pas privés là
ils se disent pas ces postes et son camp
mais non au contraire à et même bien
manger ma salade de céleri rave marie
moulade ses hôtes une rime ou
l'allégeance la peau ces conneries nous
l'a dit c'est bon là si c'est juste cet
instinct légumes râpés avec la maillot
puis de quoi ôter fake tout ça le québec
on est en train d'apprendre puis on
découvre plus on a des chefs qui nous
font c'est ricardo beaucoup fait avancer
plein d'autres aussi tantôt ça va demain
plus normal le pourcentage de plus que
toutes deux de deux projets de fermes de
la ferme que tu commences à qui les
gérait et par portable en moins par
madeleine puis apprécier la ferme des
quatre à quatre temps qui est la ferme
avec les démarrer dans la faune des
marais qui est derrière associons
derrière sur quel est le pourcentage de
thé clientèle qui sont en fait les chefs
de restaurants mais aussi de location
comme à la grelinette on nous on est
dans des cantons de l'est
donc là on n'est plus là puis on vend
notre mettre ses petits seins hector me
convainc à l'épicerie de facebook de
mesclun on a des paniers dans le
quartier saint henri
puis on fait une marche à saint lambert
et jeudi puis un marché a noté une
licence ça c'est réglé
quand j'ai commencé la firme des
quatre-temps le l'idée c'était de faire
la même chose comme 1 hector puis on
écarte à travailler sur 1 ha ok mais ton
mais là je voulais forme et plein de
monde à ses méthodes le fait que j'ai
pris comme l'ont fait comme 5 ha aussi
secteur qui l'ont ni 10 sexe mais c'est
les mêmes méthodes les mêmes outils mais
comme le terrain est plus grands noms y
plus tacleur a mise en marché et plus
importante avec leur ont fait jean talon
samedi dimanche
puis on fait une quinzaine de chefs
qu'on livre chez eux à chaque semaine
zatlers est super cool comment ça marche
et je vous envoie ce que j'ai près le
lundi matin
toi tu reçois se dire qu'il ya des
bonnes feuilles des épinards et des
radis à tout serait jean menu je veux
sur sa sociologie comme kane chef qui
décide en même temps qu'est ce qu'ils
veulent que je reçois une commande je
récolte
je vois là en livrer huit l'école juste
que tu as besoin pour ce petit jeu là
c'est super frédéric hohl qu'il avait
toujours ses carottes look et recueille
savoir toi comment 17,4
exactement non c'est ça c'est ça crée
une relation le fun petit aux autres car
ils reçoivent les commandes le les chefs
les sous-chefs toute l'équipe en cuisine
les légumes sont propres combos sont
frais sont bio sont est plutôt que comme
une autre on commence samedi à jean
talon là on a des radis des épinards des
oignons naples est ma foi il y a sacré
en baisse puis aux autres qui écoule ses
mots les gars c'est la révolution qui
m'intéresse c'est que peu apprécié il ya
en parle aux clients affecte tout le
monde est un peu dans le spirit
d'audience dont découle le local
l'agriculture bio et le maule aiguë
c'est la révolution qui mettait gens sur
les récents des anguilles mais les mots
les gars c'est la révolution
betty je la trouve tellement belle
seulement post its tellement le fun ce
n'est pas vraiment une et gatti face au
fait que les chefs ils jouent un rôle
vraiment important
si moi je les adore c'est devenu des
amis ptg est allé manger c'est que
disent faire sourire de la bombe le
célibat nature j'en ai trop brutale
quitte le self en fait tout est gelé on
y est les 4 14 15 mais qui était déjà
des récoltes de près 3 a commencé depuis
trois semaines au moins ce que tu
commences qu'à travailler la terre en
attendant l'année ben nous on a des
abril comme des tunnels comme des abris
tempo déjà si tu descends pas céder
c'est rihanna qui sont chauffés avec
sont pas chauffées quittant s'échauffer
tu dis que tu ne sert qu'à ses poches au
fit six tunnels froid aux yeux son
module jeunes sont protégés des
intempéries
la compagnie c'est dans les tunnels
froid pas chauffer quand on s'aime au
mois de février un l'on récolte commence
tomota dis moi c'est pas chauffé il
effectue des carottes que j'ai ça mais
en février des betteraves et comment ils
peuvent commencer à germer des gens
février dès qu'il fait soleil dans
l'abri le sas sapin 30° vite parce que
tu es l'effet de serre il fait 30 à
l'intérieur de sang et j'ai toujours
fait pas chauffer quand il fait soleil
c'est comme faire juin puis le soir on
les abris avec des couvertures
non on les empêche de tout et le sol se
réchauffe ça devient comme une masse
thermique ce comme une grosse batterie
l'extrême chaleur puis le soir ça la
chaleur du sol ça mais nous on met des
couvertures être la chaleur est avec les
grès bord des modèles d'une pile et
légumes ont les bords doigt puis nous
les légumes parce qu'on sait pas ce
qu'ils peuvent prendre du moins 10 s'ils
sont acclimatées s'y sont habitués
ils vont prendre du moins disent qu'ils
vont survie puis la magnifique le seul
j'ai le temps que ce gel pour l'heure si
nous autres on a dit qu'on était à la
ferme des quatre temps ça fait six ans
qu'on développe seul je veux publier un
livre en novembre sur ces techniques
l'heure mais ça c'est aussi une solution
pour manger en saison québec se disait à
place d'investir dans des grosses
erreurs qui font des tomates des
poivrons des concombres des fraises en
hiver on peux tu donner le temps il ya
des solutions qui sont donnés le 20
millions à mirabel pour faire une crosse
c'est savoureux le sergent 100 hectares
de ça j'exagère 17 ans et prend le 20
millions puis au lieu de faire 10 ha ti
2016 nam-il maraîchers l'histoire d'un
hectare puis il demandera de faire des
épinards demandeur de faire des carottes
des malheurs de faire céder des
portefeuilles des taxes à aider verdure
est tout des légumes diversifiée mais
moi je veux des tomates
on en voit qui va le début juin de voir
des tomates votre pays du nil vont être
bonnes c'est impossible
avec ces types d'écrits culture que tu
fais est impossible d'avoir à l'année
des français ben oui c'est possible
c'est si tu veux chauffé la serre pour
avoir des phrases les cas pas ce que tu
dis que je reste parce que monétairement
pied que logiquement c'est pour ces
pauvres souhaitable mais écologiquement
c'est dieu qui je vois chauffer messages
de propagande pour faire des fraises en
hiver l'électricité c'est trop chance à
l'hydroélectricité ça s'en vient mais
c'est un peu plus compliqué pour
l'instant ça va débloquer mais parce que
tu dis en place de chauffe et faire des
phrases je pourrais avoir plein de
légumes qu'ils n'ont pas besoin de
chauffage au bois ou puis il fallait
verdure c'est un pis les phrases à la
limite peut y avoir congelé bout de
souffle et des phrases en janvier mais
tâchez des fraises conflit qui date il
cite une phrase fraîchement récoltés
mais doute là vient du mexique a été
shootée en hélicoptère sandjak puis
probable le mcl pecqueux qui le ramasse
et il y en a mangé une dose sa taille
parce que la phrase qu'on mange on y va
et vient du mexique ou la californie
c'est celle qui absorbe le plus toutes
les pesticides
la phrase c'est la paix du ahly
concentre fact it à grosses fraises de
californie qui n'a pas de goût le ceta
manche puis des poisons qui met tout ça
mis ensemble dit mais pourquoi la fois
qu'on en mangerait juste pas mais où en
juin mais effectivement que nous
émettons j'en achète des fruits congelés
pour me faire des semis team ça s'est
trouvée bah oui c'est un super bonne
vingtaine à 0 et en plus ça peut être du
bio c'est encore mieux si ça peut être
des fermes du québec qui ont congeler
leurs trucs à l'automne puis bien
vengeance et sang dans des fermes comme
comme ça des firmes comme la tienne le
ton à ce que
vous faites des fruits congelés ou des
légumes congelés ou non abandonner de
50-50 légumes ce jeudi à qui bon là je
peux toutefois les fruits soit l'issue
du vote
4 temps 4 hectares de forêt de
l'habillage l'apprécient dit ok je fais
ma mise en marché d'un cdd ce n'est pas
le faire parce qu'il faut faire des
choix mais tu aurais pu décider il y en
a qui le font il y en a qui le font puis
de plus en plus il va avoir des
recruteurs temps bio qui vont faire du
fruitier des pommes des poires asiatique
super bons puisqu'ils vont faire ceux
qui vont les congeler ce qui rompt pas
vendu pilote ça va donner un oeuf à tout
le québec de manger des fruits et des
légumes en saison congelé pour les
ibères puis aussi décongeler au lieu
d'acheter parce que tu es un moment
pertes mettons dans les supermarchés
safer l'homme semble que ça me paraît
vraiment une notion de conflit que
justin
ça aussi ça va on va travailler avec du
monde qui vont avoir sur commande
ce qui est quand des producteurs
abandonner tout est au début de la
chaîne et du produit du livre que ce
soit un client donné ou c'est que ça ça
vaut le moins de pertes dans ce modèle
le modèle comme le thing c'est sûr parce
qu'on la statistique je pense de 30% de
ski et en épicerie dans le frigo cheese
et puis vous c'est quoi une perte
écoute moi car je vais aller de porter
mon panier
si toi tu feras mansaly jeter un espèce
de mauvais feeling quand un sujet tout
chuter la récolte de jardin se voit pas
de sens très bien
office of feeling lot la prochaine fois
de photos noir qui joue à cuisiner ou je
vois les données j'imagine que toi
mettons ce que tu en surplus ce qui
n'est pas vendu
ça se peut que jamais je retrouve une
patate de plus dans mon panier faut
qu'on les y en avoir quand même pas
payer paumé il m'a donné de patates
d'exactement sais que tu vas vite sonné
chercher son panier aux autres comment
fonctionne notre grande table plutôt
toutes tes légumes qui est plutôt tu
viens tu ramasses des brocolis tkr en
compte a dit c'est une botte de carottes
da salades plats la phaeton fokine
grosse pile de courgettes place est
quand même présent traître en veut parce
que ça me sort par les oreilles avec le
tout ce qui bouge a fait un gâteau ou
qui n'est finalement des surplus serop
mon père s'il y en a on les donne aux
poules puis d'attica nous sommes des
coups de mou les apolitiques
est ce que le monde ont encore tendance
à éviter les légumes est psychique dans
les épiceries souvent c'est un problème
ce site à atakpamé pas parfait que tu as
chaud de l'autre côté plus ramassées que
les fruits les légumes qui sont super
bons mais qui sont justes - d'ici là les
piscines en sont jetés sur lot
parce que maintenant les légumes qu'on
les fruits congelés que j'achète des
fois je redis comme un sac
c'est comme ces camions tommy lee fruits
il est tellement c'est comme les moches
et du sud naturellement un parfum épicé
ce qui aurait fait il y avait tout mis
les légumes les fruits moche l'apda
pitié contre 80 ans avec soi qu'ils
soient beaux ou crapaud bon là ça c'est
mon blind spot parce que la réponse à ça
c'est que c'est légal mais ont pas
besoin d'être bouclée fruits non plus ok
sauf que moi je suis maraîchers c'est ma
fierté et d'émotion
comment on pride c'est d'aider mes
légumes sont beaux sont lavés séchés
mais toutes les choses à part des
pesticides le jeu met tout en oeuvre
pour arriver à ce fait moi perso et je
me sens palette sécher quand ma fierté
c'est que tu ailles des beaux légumes
mais c'est pas grave c'est dans un trou
dans tes philips mais là ça devient je
pas le meilleur mot pour endosser sable
c'est correct et les légumes à temps je
voyais est et des poivrons le type des
poivrons qui sont vraiment pas fait sur
le mode poivrons con
compagne chez iga mettons le pied qui
était plus un ballon puis ça dans le
fond il ci-dessus juste parce que c'est
un différent type de poivrons ou c'est
juste parce que c'est la culture qui
fait que c'est pas ce thème
c'est un cultivar qu'on appelle dans la
famille des poivrons tu vas avoir j'ai
pas moins 150 pour avons différents de
différentes couleurs différentes aux
différents goûts aussi petit con quand
je parle de révolution au piquant qu'on
parlait tant tour de la l'épicerie face
à les avoir toutes nos amis c'est couci
quand tu vas l'épicerie toi un type de
poivre date au quantième on est adoptée
dans l'amour 6 puis les poivrons sont
différents et ont différents goûts puis
c'est comme ça pour les quarts
c'est comme ça pour les là dessus c'est
comme ça pour les haricots c'est comme
ceux pour les radis puits s'écoule cette
diversité là parce que le radis français
qui est longue quel bout de bhl à lui tu
veux tu être utilisé pour impressionner
ses amis dans une réception le petit rat
diront lui plus classe et fut plus qu'un
jour mais d'abord cette possibilité là
c'est super le fun mais tu ne veux pas à
l'épicerie metula chez un bon maraîchers
fait titan tôt quand on parlait de
qu'est-ce qu'on échange de ce congrès
s'est sentie avant pour revenir à mes
amis français à paris les gens dont on
entend souvent qu'à paris avant c'était
lors de vie bien manger bien boire du
sommet les jeunes y aller chercher les
cultivars il voulait cette salade la lah
tomates coeur de boeuf
tout le monde avait sa préférence ça
c'était par région place à créer des
terroirs mais ça pour moi c'est ça qu'il
faut qu'on recrée au québec mais encore
aujourd'hui moi car cela par harris
c'est une des choses qui m'a marqué
c'est qu'il n'ya pas d'épicerie si on va
chercher prendre un cadre à des
banlieues médias parient même le titre
se coucher tu va encore chercher ta
viande chez le boucher béton peint chez
boulangerie puis c'est encore sur les
habitudes puis première pile il marche
vite fait le tour du quartier pour
changer tout ce que tu as besoin de te
ramène ce fait à new york ou si c'est
comme ça
photo de ton blog moi je trouve que
c'est ce qu'ils font ne vivent en ville
parce que tu es quand et en banlieue
cc puis demande à saint-bruno cherche
les potentats semnon ça a changé c'est
il y avait ça avant quand j'étais petit
t'es tu avais la fruiterie tu avais la
charcuterie tu avais plus ça c'est tout
comme détruit puis c'est devenu un gros
gros gros et j'ai apprécié un gros ou au
métro moi j'aime quand je rentre dans un
gros gros metro le 1 je déteste ces
mêmes je veux pas parler à personne je
n'ai pas envie d'avoir 52 mille sortes
de céréales mansac je trouve c'est
impersonnel pis j'aime ça me convient
pour moi j'aimerais mieux que jeu des
plus petits plus intimes je connais je
vais peut-être rencontré ma voisine
bonjour je sais pas convivial on
pourrait être remplacé les épiceries par
des marchés dans le fond qu'une épicerie
c'est incitant à acheter
oui c'est déjà le même modèle mais c'est
ce qui va arriver parce que quand les
gens y ont goûté à ce que je t'emmène
décret en date sur vos bouteilles tout
ceux des fockers l'épicerie c'est pas ça
me convient pas aux bolton
sa jambe est toujours en analogie des
bières parce que je trouve qu'elle est
bonne si c'est comme si quelqu'un qui
s'ennuient de rentrer au dépanneur
c'était juste des produits molson n'ont
tourné comme hier c'est cool
d'encourager plein microbrasserie tu
pars tout petit je faisais remarquer
mais il y en a beaucoup
oui mais ça c'est autre 6ème beaucoup
qui continue d'exister c'est donc un
intérêt place aussi pourquoi fait
qu'effectivement qui cite la tension est
tranquillement excès quand est-ce que
l'épicerie finalement à vos frais plein
cultivars de radis dantesques les fries
il faut savoir que telle phrase ça c'est
celle oct aime bien aussi ce différend
ça ce serait le fun mais tu vois ce que
tu dis le moi tai chi chi chi paul ferré
là dedans je pensé qu'un pauvre ancien
pauvre on est piqué comme fait qu'à
l'épicerie on l'est comme habitués de
voir tout le temps le même type
d'affaires la même ma femme du pasteur
d'art design guillemets mais en fait la
nature cpasp au standard on appelle ça
en anglais monoculture of the mind
cette entrée aussi de nous rendre un peu
comme des débiles
parce que la monoculture ce qu'on fait
dans les champs c'est aussi ce qu'on
devient un petit c'est la diversité
c'est la couleur c'est c'est tout ça qui
fait qu' on est heureux fait que si on
la cultive pas cette diversité là aussi
j'imagine cathy par la manne et des
belges eddy k comme il ya des espèces
animales en voie d'extinction des plans
dans mon extinction c'est c'est fou le
on prêt à partir sur mon sujet mais le
progrès ou tel qu on le définit
aujourd'hui là on pense toujours que
c'est par en avant pis que ça va être
quelque chose qui s'en vient mais le
progrès c'est souvent juste des choses
qu'on a fait qu'on a oublié puis
clairement donné on ne tourne à droite
mais dans le fond il s'arrêter mieux
qu'on continue qu'on tourne à gauche ça
s'arrêtait plus plus progressistes qui
mois
toutes les dates choisies t direction
c'est toutes les techniques que j'ai mis
en oeuvre depuis que je raconte dans mon
livre ses mots quand je retourne à paris
puis en france là bas mon travail il pas
célébrer parce que sa bible
toutes ces méthodes là mais eux ils
avaient tout oublié
c'est à travers moi je me suis inspiré
d'un américain qui lui s'inspirer d'un
but français
en fait parce que mon livre décrit un
francis ces techniques club ces méthodes
là qui faisait le c'était comme la
gloire de paris ça revient en france
puis les gens redécouvrent ses façons de
travailler bientôt de la bolt moi j
invente presque riehl fake c'est ça
c'est dans le fond on réapprend à vivre
comme avant
puis des fois le progrès le lait
maternel en mode fumer dans les avions
c'est les annonces d'un médecin si les
textes et en espère attirer des médecins
qui faisait des années
c'est clair qu'il ya plein gamiq comme
ça aujourd'hui qu'il faut encore des
construit déconstruit de construire est
ce que est ce que c'est une fausse
statistique que je me rappelle je ne
peux pas dire la source ni l'endroit
mais semble que c'etait 90% des légumes
qu'on consomme
ces vins et légumes ça se pourrait je
sais que 70 viennent de peau du québec
110 % des légumes qu'on mange d'un petit
cabinet ceci c'est débile mais j'étais
plus dans l'optique d'aider manque de
diversité la doua s'agit me semble que
c'etait sapptech 20 j'exagère que vince
même plus je pense pas que ce soit une
dizaine parce que j'avais vu la liste
puisque des genres et des carottes
brocoli patate oignons un genre chou
chou fleur puis il y en avait une coupe
d'autres qui étaient calmes qui
constituait 90% des légumes consommés la
société occidentale
ça se peut des types de légumes
il y en a tabarnak oui on a cru que sur
combien y en aurait maintenant avec
après avoir facilement 50 légumes
différents puis dans les cinq ans de
légumes 25 intéressant c'est fait que je
suis vraiment poche en mathématiques
vous ça me pose même pas dire un chiffre
une trompe est complètement les
obtiendrait beaucoup pour la dizaine qui
constituent 90% de ce qu'on consomme
dans le fond le client note ses légumes
fleurs qui vont pousser mieux en quelque
sorte pouces et moins bien ailleurs
puis c'est toute l'idée de terroir c'est
ça aussi ça y est c'est comme moi quand
je m'en veux dans charlevoix
mais c'est les fromages charlevoix parce
que les brebis
ils mangent de l'herbe ça l'est parce
que ses proches du fleuve
c'est le fromage et où les bleues du lac
i bleues et du l'affecté c'est toutes
ces affaires là c'est tout à redécouvrir
pittis qui est le fun là dedans petit
peut-être que toi aujourd'hui thé commun
et moi je t'ai pas d'entrer plus de
manger comme ça mais c'est un voyage qui
peut commencer aujourd'hui c'est pas
grave c'est comme on découvre tout seul
on est on est toute une génération
à découvrir sur huit sites des artisans
des couleurs ils sont c'est comme au
chinois aujourd'hui mes amis un autre
fermier c'est comme un autre va être
complètement ces femmes si l'éclat
monétaire est aussi à découvrir la
cuisine d'ailleurs au pit et avenches
potes mais petit mes parents n'ont
jamais fait 2-2
recette ci dessous mais on le fait pour
ailleurs mais ce qu'on le fait pour lui
si ses enfants parce que mettons que tu
penses d'exemple le magma tu fais un
poulet général tao le tu peux faire tout
comme étant l'auteur fut un temps où tu
peux faire tout avec des enfants s'il a
besoin de rien qui vient de se reposer
là dessus donc l'usiné ailleurs
découvrir la cuisine d'ailleurs avec des
ingrédients de 6 se poserait 4 à la
cuisine on voyage comme si pour
découvrir nos québec
c'est fait c'est beau et puis le cas ni
le crabe des neiges quand on s'intéresse
un peu ordinaire pilotis serait à la
limite vous un terrain de revues petit
lirez sur le doute qui ramasse les
crabes
c'est quoi sa vie à lui tu sais comme
tout intéressant ça pour moi facture
quand je reviens à mon terme de
révolution secte est pour moi ces choses
là c'est l'évolution naturelle de dire
on va partir d'une monoculture dans le
champ d'une monoculture dans les
épiceries d'une monoculture dans notre
société vers la diversité apprécié qu on
est différent et ça ça s'applique aussi
pour les races pour les lampes pour la
musique
ces ondes au dessus juste écouter c'est
quoi ou qui comptera d'abord plaint
postes qu'ils proposent plein fouet rien
compte c'est quoi c'est vraiment comme
une idée qu'au québec te monte limité de
parler climat mais le tout dicks
commencé très doucement par année 12
mois par année dans un secteur public le
nom mais également non finis fête
commence acer en février puis en
descente récolte encore je récolte en
descendant champ des choses qui ont gelé
qui ont dégelé qui ont gelé qui ont
dégelé ramos puis je remplis cave aussi
petit
j'ai des légumes sont en serre qui sont
en dormance décembre janvier février
avec son tout le jeu les chauves pape il
pousse plus ils sont là puis là comme on
mars arrive lorsque la lumière est bonne
il peu plus de chaleur je commence à
récolter puis dans fois il ya vraiment
comme juste janvier finalement qui est
un peu le petit break que tu peux avoir
web et si j'ai envie tu peux aussi
décider de chauffer puis dans tout ça
fait
et on peut faire des pousse ses pions
peut sortir les légumes du caveau fêté
en janvier ça se fait aussi capable
d'avoir des épinards jeu capable d'avoir
10 pouces 6 chauffe un peu je peux avoir
la roquette je peux avoir plein de trucs
la presse a devient un peu moi ma
vitesse ma vie il faut que tu choisisses
aussi moi j'avais choisi ce métier là
parce que je les mettais les uns des
plus grands questionnements ton appareil
la chanson en piste et justement à ce
que ces modèles qui qui super noble qui
puisse faire boum qui se passe est ce
que on peut l'appliquer at large cm2 par
la conversation qu'ont neuf départs
cette logique leur site wat produit plus
par rock que celui qui quitta de sang et
or qu il faut tout fait plus de légumes
thé avec ton qu'avec un homme qui lui
fait avec un autre nom
ben si on t'adore disque dans le fond
finalement pour le même territoire peut
produire plus de nourriture
sauf que ça ne travaillent plus de fermi
apprendre des fermes ici c'est ça la clé
cette fois intéresse tout à la fois ta
mission c'est d'intéresser le monde à
cette ville
c'est sa fille je la trouve belle pour
vrai si je peux je sois un rendu de ces
mots comme souvent je veux dire aux gens
c'est un phoque une beau métier mon
reste à la moye et débile je me lève le
matin je plonge dans mon étang et des
libellules apprécié je prends mon café
je fais le tour de mes jardins si je
travaille toute la journée chez nous
dans mon petit quand mon groupe otages
et je livre des légumes les jeunes
apprécient chez du cash c'est le
flambeau mercredi fermiers c'est le
parti me va je voyage sauf qu'en même
temps forts quand suppose que tu fais
dans ce métier leur petite taille tout
improvise l'autre peut facilement de
détails
maison proton borreill devient une
espèce de catastrophe parce que tes
légumes sont mangés par les insectes des
clients sont pas contents te demander
remboursement sur les paniers parce
qu'ils étaient pas nié son y est fait il
faut que tu saches qu'est ce que tu fais
avec moi ça a toujours été dit le
leinster est cool mais gardent des
manuels techniques c'est le jardinier
maraîchers de son livre technique elle
sait que voici comment fais tu
travailles si tu veux que ce soit le
fond de ta vie c'est ça parce que
j'entendais dire qu'ils avancent
ça existait des des lignes sur le sujet
mais c'était plus philosophique
ésotérique puis les valeurs mes projets
tpr antennes râteaux que c'est ça le bo
leicester il vient quand tu es compétent
sinon c'est un cauchemar le web ça peut
qu'il y en a beaucoup qui l'ont vécu tu
es un homme book bien obame beaucoup qui
m'ont qui m'ont suivi écouté pitt et
pour mieux gérer présenter le rail
fillon sont allées dans ce trailer plus
sculptée il a ils sont le cas moi j'en
martin parce que l'idée c'est aussi faux
que soient préparées toute sa jeunesse
du fep faudra être fort mais tu es les
bonnes techniques les bonnes méthodes
mais c'est pas si compliqué non plus
inaccessibles fait qu on met personne
sans lune
non mais personne ça allume qui t'as pas
besoin d'être grand musicien il n'était
pas besoin d'être grand acteur c'était
juste besoin d'avoir un minimum de
compétences organisationnelles qui sait
gérer une équipe de trop c'est pour la
fin du monde c'était pour gérer une
équipe de trois bons et coûte peut-être
que ce sera bon marché
ouais j'ai je veux souhaiter un petit
peu la conversation dans le petit coup
je parle un peu de vega nice joue et
gagne puis je le suis pour
l'environnement en premier lieu puis par
l'environnement j'ai ensuite appris un
petit peu et sensibiliser à la cause
animale
puis les terres agricoles puis la
monoculture le je pense que la
statistique 70% des terres agricoles
dans le monde entier sont dédiés à
nourrir le bétail le monsieur se permet
tout à condensation convient d'abord
c'est un cauchemar ça c'est ça c'est la
brique
une aberration c'est la plus grande
destruction de la planète en grains
poussé pour nourrir les animaux la
monoculture pour mettre ce pour faire
passer la protéine dans un tierce partie
qu'on consomme après ce cher c'est la
pire chose c'est c'est quand on se
promène au québec 3 du maïs c'est pour
les animaux c'est pour les animaux puis
c'est ça qui sait ce qui détruit les
sols ceux qui polluent les rivières puis
en plus les vaches c'est des herbivores
hockey une vache là pourquoi les vaches
sont sacrées en inde
pourquoi la vache c'est tellement
quelque chose de puissant c'est que
prononça le décor il est comme ça ça
capte l'énergie
ok c'est vrai mais ça leur désistement
fait pour être capable de manger de
l'herbe qu'il a digéré d'être capable de
transformer tout ça en protéines
puisqu'elle a besoin poète une vache
c'est la même chose avec un chevreuil ou
un orignal quand ils donnent du grain
pour la faire grossir plus vite elles
sont estomaqués parfaite pour manger se
fait que leur avaient développé plein de
side effects et éventuellement à va
tomber malade et donc c'est vrai que je
lui donnais des antibiotiques et donc
vous êtes obligés de et donc est donc
identique et met à vendre aussi puis il
faut faire plus de cash fake tout seul
tout ce que tu viens de décrire
c'est c'est vraiment pitié des vaches
nourries aux grains dans des dents des
key foule qu'on apprend dans l'île c'est
comme ça comme des milliers de la
charente et de l'autre ceux des images
d'horreur moi tous ces gens voyaient
seul il deviendrait tout dit que c'était
comme un corner qui disait si il parle
de lui parler des abattoirs les dix
utilisent abattoirs avait défini il y
aurait beaucoup plus de végétariens
en ville pour voir ce qui se passe
derrière seul fait moi je tape hui 150
pour moi je peux wegen on a pitié je
serais moi je mange de l'herbe de la
viande nourries à l'herbe c'est justin
les élevages sont comme ça mais je tape
puissant pour sa part et quand tu
comprends ce fait comme fuck merde c'est
la destruction dans le fond moi j'ai
plusieurs niveaux dans mon idéologie
mettons le nous puis la première chose
pour moi ajus proscrire
c'est la viande d'élevage industriel
mais pour autant le traitement des
animaux que pour l'environnement pour
tout seul mois c'est la chose numéro un
amateur qui fait aucun sens j'ai
beaucoup d'amis chercheurs mais tant
qu'ils mangent que la viande qui subit
ce pour moi c'est vraiment vraiment
mieux fait la question qui vient ensuite
pour le haut niveau en dessous de dire
je vais faire un retourné un petit peu
plus tôt dans conversations quand je
parlais que moi quand j'essaie
d'imaginer une solution ses pour
l'entièreté de la population active et
puis j'entends ce que tu dis de dire je
consomme juste la viande qui est grasse
fed
fringe dans des environnements éthique
qui doit en guise mais la réalité c'est
qu'on manquerait des espaces
si tout le monde mangeait le même
quantité de viande qu'on mange
maintenant parce que ça prendrait trop
de place pour que ces conditions là
soient respectés et fait qu'on puisse
faire ce premier le détail d'un champix
ce soit éthiquement correct qu'est ce je
suis pas sûr de ce que je suis pas sûr
parce que le modèle dans le fond qu'est
ce qu'ils ont fait aux questions les
vaches d'absolument c'est ce qu'annonce
d'un pâturage
il y va je serai dans le pâturage il
voudrait de l'herbe
jeudi les vaches est fait pour manger de
l'herbe sauf que lorsqu'on 6 10 et n'a
ainsi pas très commode que les vaches
soit tout ce qu'on va faire ses combats
au début on va vraiment c'est l'herbe
puis on va les mettre dans une errance
et après on va donner de l'air et là
c'est moins de travail ce mois une
manipulation que les vaches sont toutes
à la même place on peut tout les soigner
tout le temps il sort plus plab son
voile à donner du grain plaimont gros
c'est ça c'est devenu industriel de cds
une grosse étape mais à la base
cit avait toutes les chances sont en
maïs aujourd'hui parce que finalement le
maïs c'est pas juste pour nourrir les
vaches du québec
ça s'en va dans le marché mondial du
grain avec le tout les maïs qu'on voit
au québec
c'est pour ça s'en va en bateau pour le
brésil la colline pour aller bloquer
mais si on prenait tout c'est à elle
qu'on se disait à la place de faire du
maïs de polluer nos rivières de détruire
nos sols on va faire de l'herbe qui on
va mettre des vaches sur ce ce qui
arriverait ça fait deux choses c'est que
quand il fait pousser de l'herbe
ces caisses du carbone d'hector l'herbe
ses caisses plus de carbone que des
forêts fait que c'est la réinsertion sur
deux dans les actuelles lois communément
les chiens la vache aviez manger l'herbe
elle à l'envoi un signal aux brins
d'herbe de se régénérer
parce que leur faut faire face plus de
racines pour repousser l'un des caciques
est plus de carbone fait dans le fond
dans le cycle naturel les herbivore et
les prairies ont fait pousser de l'herbe
on parle de prairies les deux
fonctionnent dans un écosystème qui est
naturel qui se régénère puis ses caisses
du carbone donc là je me suis perdu dans
max ans la question étant par livre moi
j'avais j'avais lu la statistique puis
ça semble être comme accepter le par liv
de vian
ça prend comme cette fois plus de place
pour faire c'est de ce type le de
l'agriculture sauf que ça ça tient pas
compte du fait que tu fais mille fois
plus de grain parce que tu nous as
portait exactement ça se fait que dans
le fond cette idée là et comme floue et
nous faudrait rechercher un petit peu
les terres l'état si on disait au québec
qui nous on veut séquestrer du carbone
puis on veut cesser illégales qu'elles
aient ou via soient pollués comme seuls
les gueux j'espère les allées parlez
dans votre vie parce que ça par rapport
comme c'était plus le droit de polluer
leur violence et wall e je m'en fous ce
que tu fais ta ferme et hop taux zéro
droit de m et 0 2 point correct dans les
rangs on veut plus que les verseaux
pollue et on veut séquestrer du carbone
puis que le marché du maïs mondial
on s'en sert qu'on le fond le
subventionnent puis pendant le seul
ancien et à 60 pour celles qui ne le
soutiennent plus fait le ont dit ok tout
sans hector fait de l'air bon gars mais
mille vaches vivante et millevaches puis
le tout les fermes fonce je sais pas à
quel point ce serait pas vraiment mieux
maintenant si ces vaches là des gens
comme toi qui sont super sensibiliser à
la cause animale
si ce serait différent parce que le les
vaches qui ont une belle vie oui il joue
un rôle écologique puis tu quand tu la
manges cc c'est quelque chose de quelque
chose de sacré un peu plus strict mais
là sous questions à ceux c'est faux
quand même terminé la vie de la vache
dans son premier tiers en haïti qui est
une quête qui est une question que moi
je trouve vraiment offre saas permettant
mettons qu'on se dire maintenant qu'on
se dit l'objectif si justement de faire
pousser de l'herbe puis de faire la
conversion de co2 moi je suis sûr à 100
% le dax it
sauf que comment est ce que j'ai de la
difficulté à me justifier de dire on va
faisons ce mais chaque vache dans lequel
on a investi du temps de l'argent on
veut juste de manger la manger routière
de servi à place
l'essai réinsérer le co2 dentaire
pendant une vie complet à la besoin
d'être à la pas besoin d'être sur un sig
ii a pourrait vivre sa vie de vache mais
une fois qu'ils mettront la viande qu'on
mange on pourrait pas la manger c'est à
fin de sa vie oui maintenant une vache
qui meurt de sa vieillesse le voudrait
c'est sûr que tu vas gerin trop s'il
faut choisir quel vaches vers l'abattoir
au petit point et les questions éthiques
aussi spirituelle peut être abandonnées
dit qu'ils ont battus élevé des vies
pour libre oui parce que contre la
conterie réponse à ceux qui me suis
positionné par rapport à ceux c'est
sinon les vaches dispute
ouais c'est quoi qu'on fait parce que si
nous on essaie d'arrêter ce cycle là les
vaches et les cochons tout ce ça existe
putté métier c'est c'est vraiment des
délégations qui a pas de vrai ou faux
procès du moustoir contre 91 dans la
confrontation
c'est super on va ta façon d'en parler
au japon c'est vraiment de comprendre
que dans l'écologie
2 comment un paysage fonctionnent les
herbivore y ont un rôle de premier en
corde à jouer sont ceux qui avaient des
troupeaux de caribous ce pour ceux qui
avaient des troupeaux de chevreuil c'est
que la prairie c'est un écosystème
vraiment riche puis la vache est là
vient jouer le rôle l'air du vol 12 la
vache miss tenir bon a bien joué le rôle
de manger l'herbe puis de la piété qui
avaient des troupeaux avant le qu'est ce
qui arrive est ok litres baudet des
bisons mathon étaient des centaines de
milliers épisode se promener les autres
y arriver à un spot y manger toute
l'herbe il piétinait fichiers ok féclaz
leurs sabots faisait que le sol était un
peu travailler il y avait du fumier fait
que cette terre là était pleine de marc
mais prête à fonctionner le pré sal ça
faisait pas ou parce que c'est régénéra
cesser ses actions régénération
d'écologie il ya une perturbation le
troupeau arrive puis le l'herbe la
prairie est là se régénère bien encore
plus forte avec le trim le troupeau va
repasser un an plus tard ils vont faire
la même chose
fake cela c'est le futur mondial pour
séquestrer le carbone c'est la solution
mais le à ce qu'on va réintroduire des
troupeaux de bisons sauvage
je pense pas mais les vaches peuvent
jouer sans leurs une jolie fermiers qui
font bien ce qu'ils font c'est qu'ils
profèrent l'effet propos qui vont
clôturer des petites parcelles ils vont
dire contre 1 hector le g100 vaches sont
là pour une demi-journée
ils vont la bougie en privons la bouche
à notre place le lendemain le comme ça
puis le sépare c'est la liste régionale
après ça de manger ou pas la vache c'est
en n é et mange pas et va même si l'os
il cela les c'est ce que j'ai de la
misère à accepter ce type parce que je
me dis pourquoi c'est parce que tu es
parce que l'art est là pourquoi c'est
que dans nos écosystèmes nordiques de
l'herbe
il n'y a pas beaucoup de byte nous on
peut pas manger de l'herbe
donc si t'es pas capable de métaboliser
lherm ta diète est pas complète métier
aujourd'hui mondialisées du programme de
futur et même je te fut initialement
fois j'ai dit que ça venait de la beauce
ne savez pas la bossa vient de projets
du prochain mariage j'ai oublié encore
la place les la petite-fille du proprio
d'une série qui m'a écrit pour me
corriger plus jolie parade vers le bon
choix la société l'oeil a pas de réponse
que le soya ccc tu fais du labo tu mets
des engrais de détracteurs temps une
usure du temps fut bio est ce que c'est
des grandeurs céder la bourse et des
engrais ses détracteurs c'est des usines
tandis qu'une vache c'est naturel et la
mange l'herbe claque à métabolisme tout
ça tout mange la vache pour chercher des
protéines titre insisterait sic écologie
excuse pas partie d'une usine que c'est
nécessairement négatif le dessus d'un
processus mettons nos skis que les
mettons le danseur je comprends que si
plus naturel mais en même temps on
parlait à
olivier bernard qui nous parlait des ogm
comme de quoi c'est comme le mot fait
peur mais qu'au final des fois c'est
c'est positif dans la vie
mettons que le challenge grec ogm c'est
aussi une gamme iq où ils ont fêté
veulent faire de l'argent puis contre
moulins pl
mettez la diète quand on en discute
c'est c'est comme un peu la religion la
politique
jeudi quand quelqu'un a une idée c'est
dur la faire changer des arguments quand
même objectif ouais donc on peut compter
les statistiques existent c'est fait il
qu on peut quand même discuté sans
tomber dans l'émotion de ces sujets le
même temps c'est s'écoule l'émotion mais
c'est moi moi mon rise en fait la
position qui peut adopter c'était
l'écologie de l'air beevor de la prairie
de la régénération des sceaux c'est
vraiment important et peut être viggen
puis appuyer ce fonds lorrain me suces
qc ça parce que dans le fond tout
dimanche viggen pour ma santé juste
contente pas manger de viande ses hôtes
parfaits cool
les agriculteurs qui font seuls qui
remplace ce qui est vraiment dégueulasse
qui est qui la monoculture de maïs mille
fois mieux c'est sa position du dimanche
higgins content toi ce fait de
l'agriculture régénérative tête est
infirmier qui fait des boeufs nourries à
l'herbe même temps on supporte man loves
lot vient un peu de briser le clash
fonds d'investissement c'est ma position
complète le sait mais tout se passe tu
qu un monde où où la population est
viguen cc6 tenez bon je pense que oui
parce que dans des pays comme l'inde
puis dans plein de pays
traditionnellement leur essayer le monde
mangeait pas de viande
ouais moi je pense que oui c'est suis
prouvé que c'est pas ce même localement
d'avoir une diète 100% équilibrer le
regarde même juste en faisant bien venez
fait que je me dis sauf qu est ce que c
désirable ça c'est une autre question
c'est la chasse au québec l'an passé
lego vous êtes un peu c'est big daddy g
en gaspésie qui ont du talent d'un
territoire le
pour pour un pour une famille chassé son
orignal c'est au coeur de leur vie qu'on
en oublie ça parce qu'on est à montréal
parce que la chasse mais titre i'm en
gaspésie les territoires de chasse et
bella dans leur frigo c'est de la viande
de chien puis ça jeter les eskimos qui
habitait ici les autochtones sont
quelque chose là dedans qu'il faut qu'on
aurait pu dire 10e mais eux l'impact
vraie mentalité de cette chasse le
minimes le pratiquement notre apport
tout les cas troupes sont achetés puis
ou des espèces méthodes effet une
surpopulation de tels types d'effort
pilotis et sasso à d'autres impacts son
environnement fait qu'il ya un équilibre
à trouver quand même là dedans qui
moisit sauf que je pense que c'est dans
je pense qu'on s'entend tout le monde
dont la table sur 80 17% du point
monétique puis 97% du point
moi je je je les dis l'autre fois je
l'apprends fois que ça apprend enfin que
je le verbaliser l'appui la question
c'est est est ce que je serais capable
je m'en veux plus te tiens quelqu'un me
pose une question laisse que très
capable de tamié avec quelqu'un qui est
que 0 en temps mais la réflexion
environnementale piqué fait juste acheté
trois fois par jour de la viande à
l'épicerie
puis la personne me pose la question
d'un point de vue et il ma réponse était
pas d'un point de vue éthique mais
c'était plus de l'ordre de 6 la personne
pas encore en 2021 en sachant tout ce
qu'on sait comment c'est une réflexion
par rapport à l'environnement même si 72
dash au quotidien ça sera pas quelqu'un
avec qui je pourrais être amis parce
qu'on va être trop séparés sur un tueur
de coki fondamentale fait que ce n'est
pas l'idée que la personne consomment de
la viande qui fait que je serai pas ami
avec son manque de consensus l'idée que
peut-être on dit alors rendu à la même
place dans notre raisonnement puis on
peut pas si on peut pas être même parlé
de tirs puis enfin je pense que l'idée
puisse tout le monde qu'ils écoutent ce
puits
évidemment tout depuis le début la
conversation je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
de monde qui vont avoir allumé que moi
sont toutes les enjeux qui nous amène
six mois je peux amener un enjeu de plus
il enchaîne pas vous passer au profit de
mazen moi je peux dire les noms de shy'm
chipe la balle mais moi je fais taper
ses doigts gourds rené encore votre
viande pour la semaine cédant qu est ce
que la certification bio c'est un gage
que ces étiquettes achète ce que tu le
nom est il éthique sûrement parce que ça
l'est pour toit en toit c'est de là que
tout dans le fond comment s'appelle ce
que tu fais l'écriture de proximité
proximité avec ces bio mais c'est encore
plus que se base pas ce que tu sais d'où
ça vient du bio en californie ce qui est
plate c'est pour ça que tout est une
discussion c'est pour ça que c'est le
fond de ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui parce
que si t'as pas le temps dans ta vie de
prendre le temps de s'informer sur ces
quads ligue à nice puis pourquoi si t'as
pas le temps c'est comme si tu passes à
côté tout même parce que c'est pas vrai
que toutes et tous
coquelicots de recettes le bio oui c'est
mieux pour toi c'est sur le bio qui
viennent la californie le mois j'ai
visité chaleur ça c'est pas 30 km de
broccolis et ses dix 10 km de brocoli
zone technique c'est quand même 10 km
dans le colisée banking toutes les
parties sans aller retour ça va aller
retour sur un demi marathon pour faire
évoluer la réglementation bio mettons
states versés au québec elle soit pas là
maintenant est dilué le pilote non cccc
les états unis c'est big business avec
time c'est la californie y produisent
80% et légumes pour toute l'amérique du
nord qui fait qu'un que ya un mouvement
qui dit on veut du bio puisqu'elle a eu
toutes des fermiers de famille dans
toutes les études toute l'amérique du
nord
dans toutes les villes dans le village
ait eu des gens comme moi qui étais le
samedi matin à faire la promotion de
tout quarante ans ça a créé une prise de
conscience qui est devenu important le
peut aux autres qu'ils ont fait c'est
que les normes environnement les normes
biologiques qui ont été dilués pour
pouvoir accepter plus de gros joueurs
dans la patente parce que le lac immense
il faut honorer les gens du bio sa
légende à manseau fait qu'on voit la
lorraine d'offrir le toujours sur
l'animal est possible pour honorer le
monde
il faut que ouais c'est pour ça que j'en
reviens toujours à dire ont sacré sont
venues nourrir le village parce que tu
élimines beaucoup de ces faux argument
là mais bref la l'hydroponie qu est
certifiée bio aux états unis ça veut
dire que une plante qui poussait dans
une dans un substrat d'eau avec des
engrais de poissons des engrais
chimiques des engrais bio et stimulante
ce média pas de soi il ya pas mal de
talent et pas de vie dans le sol et par
micro organismes ça c'est bio maintenant
qu'ils traitaient fadil et tuent dans
des entrepôts avec des lampes puis je
savoir un truc verticale hydroponique
avec des poissons ou des réussissent pas
tripale c'était un peu un ingénieur tout
capote
mais l'image que tu me dis c'est
poétique c'est pas beau c'est pôle image
jeune cultivateur qui n'ont dans un
bourg la terre et non mais c'est bio oui
oui c'est bio mais en quoi ces mauvais
mal s'ils portent beau je veux te dire
pourquoi parce que il ya du monde qui
pendant 40 ans on éduquer sensibiliser
on dit aux gens écouter le ce qu'on fait
nous sommes affirme à la grelinette
c'est ça que tu veux manger plus votre
l'ex qui vient voir je te l'expliquer le
bio est devenue une opposition à un
modèle qui malsain qui chimiques tu veux
pas manger pesticides de poc
les employés se fasse sauter des
pesticides non plus il ya eu toute une
éducation pileux le bio est devenu jeu
comme une big business il ya la big
business a pas nié la norme ece qui
décide c'est quoi la norme c'est ce qui
est grave
je me suis un peu le toi tu t'en vas ou
géo tâche est ton pauvre en bio petite
pièce on parle de solutions supply chain
deux pays
une cinquante de plus voire un poivron
depuis deux heures dans un money petit
dans ta tête dit fathi hachicha j'te
sacrifices si je m'achète pas peut-être
d'autres choses pour ça c'est de la
merde ce que tu achètes pareil
parce que c'est pas un poivron qui a été
fait dans l'esprit du bio c'est devenu
une certification qui dilue et qui veut
punir et dire grand chose aux états unis
au québec au canada
on n'a pas les mêmes pressions
économiques fait qu'on n'a pas cédé mais
aux etats-unis aujourd'hui sexy c'est
chez walmart tout votre bio tout va être
poussé dans un entrepôt à côté 7e délai
depuis de repos ni tout des légumes
hydroponique midi dans l'hydroponie moi
ça fait 20 ans que j'étudie les sols que
je travaille les sols que je comprends
un peu que je comprends rien il est
vraiment puisque tout ce que je mange
comme un légume ça vient tout ça pluton
sol et en santé plutôt de voir l'auteur
plus et diversifiée plutôt de vitamines
plus moi je tends santé oms légumiers 8
bon je me fais c'est de dire on élimine
tout ça puis on fait juste diderot
panique laisse pas le lait maternel bois
le lait en poudre qu'on te fait pour toi
avec toutes les vitamines ajouté c'est
comme c'est ça qu'il faut pour sortir de
toute excuse
l'aspect jeu tu es tu mélanges et la tue
non parce que c'est des gros enjeux de
ces gamins parle de certification ce que
je maintiens que certains ici mais tant
qu'on achète un produit bio produits du
québec ont eux ont plus les bonnes
confiance qu'on a fait un bon choix
grippe il ça va arriver que des grosses
grosse grosse grosse grosse ferme en bio
tient dans les serres ou si ça va
arriver mais c'est mieux mais c'est la
californie là c'est pour prier allie
souvent c'est quand même je veux pas
encourager sa c4 et s'éloigne la fois
que je devais prendre en laye et traquer
pas nécessaire fait que d'un point de
vue de la santé
ouais est ce que dans ce genre de
productions le on va perdre des vies des
vitamines et minéraux qu'on retrouve
dans les légumes pousser dans les terres
travailler pour ça c'est sûr c'est sûr
que quand il fait des légumes dans un
sol stérile parce que tu es grand faut
quand même les engrais c'est ce qu'on
parlait d'entre eux plus temps mais plus
les pauvres plus fortement ce moment
donné il vient comme inertes
c'est comme ces salles un impact dans ce
qui pose pas parce que l'hélium lui il
devient premièrement beaucoup plus
fragile parce que pour tout ce qui est
besoin donc le développent des carences
lui-même fait que les plus susceptibles
de se faire attaquer par des insectes
les essais qui vont toujours à l'hiver
c'est comme un peu en nature le tout
comme le prédateur il va attaquer la
proie qui la plus faible avec l'insa qui
fait ça aussi
citons légumes là il n'y a pas développé
son système immunitaire
il n'y a pas ce qu'il faut pour se
défendre il va se voir attaquer donc tu
vas mettre des pesticides
donc c'est seulement ça continue le ca
continue donc juin quand tu l'aies genre
toi tu dois cesser nutriments lent moins
en moins et ceux où vivent en plus si tu
lis dans un qui dans le on était en
train de on est en train d'évaluer toute
la valeur nutritive qui a été perdue
depuis 40 ans c'est pas juste
comment légumes et pousser mais c'est
aussi des fois la graine c'est le
cultivar comme le la tomate
mirabel ou la tomate je peins big beef
si c'est une graine qui désole si si
c'est quelque chose qui a été [ __ ]
hybride et en laboratoire qui a été
travaillé travaillé parce qu'on voulait
avant grosse thomas qui elle se conserve
dans le truck alors pas été sélectionnés
parce qu'ils étaient bonnes nutritives
qui lie le goût est souvent social à
valeur nutritionnelle aussi et les sucs
s'agit beaucoup fait qu on a eu beaucoup
beaucoup de pertes de des clubs des
semences qui avait des valeurs
nutritives fait que les aujourd'hui
beaucoup de ce qu'on achète légumes et
poussé en conventionnel et en plus la
semence
elle avait déjà plus beaucoup de
nutriments cette love story shirt c'est
moi je vais pas être un apport de maradi
j'arrive avec des bonnes nouvelles on a
une alternative c'est tout ça cette
monoculture là c'est faut sortir de ça
c'est tout pas bon du début à la fin les
gens qui en profite là c'est les gens
qui ont les portefeuilles des erreurs
puis les gens qui en paye le prix c'est
nous puis souvent c'est con parce qu'on
est on va être les premiers à défendre
ces systèmes noir ou non de d'une idée
que les éditions veut pas comme à cuba
mexique va arriver là on va être comme
paris bhl s'en voit ce que tout le monde
allait chercher ses beaux produits puis
les gens avaient du bon vin et des
collègues des images et des bons
fromages bleus du bon vin travail et
d'un chat c'est possible de vivre ça
qu'on a besoin de révolution puisque où
est ce que les gens tu y vois ce que les
gens peuvent
année la revue gros on a pas besoin de
s'éterniser
mais pour moi c'est une façon de mettre
en lumière qu'en couleur tout les gens
qui sont font partie c'est ce que je
vous ai parlé aujourd'hui puisqu'elle va
te découvres et s'est coincé qui
pourquoi ils font ça parce que tu es moi
j'ai passé ma vie professionnelle à
montrer aux gens comment travailler mais
le pourquoi tu fais ça et qu l'entente
on indique odile motive tout le matin
j'écoutais fermiers c'est pourquoi à
nice est et qui fait découvrir sa voix
est un personnage extraordinaire un
apiculteur à ferme-neuve voyez vraiment
préoccupé des abeilles celui là il voit
ce qui se passe depuis vingt ans les
hommes je suis vraiment préoccupé que
j'ai jamais vue sur 6 et des histoires
intéressant où il ya des sports ce pas
positif mais la levure raconte
l'histoire d'aujourd'hui avec justement
tous les projets le tire justement
êtes-vous dans les messieurs le bronze
ce nouveau projet le kiki qui la revue
pius et les produits pitié le taux tous
lancé tu t'habilles de relancer le
jardiniers maraîchers mais t'es fait un
autre livre aussi en collaboration place
ménage avec la facture beaucoup de
projets parallèles
est ce que est ce qui est encore dans
chaque jour où bo cette année cette
année là ça a été c'est ma première
année où est ce que je vis le phénomène
zoom tout ça passe par rendez vous pis
là je viens de me rendre compte que
christie le fait qu'on book des rendez
vous pour me parler tout le temps ça
fait en sorte que j'ai toujours coupé
dans mon élan ce qu'un blog j'aurai
l'après midi pour aller faire quelque
chose mais non ils rendez-vous zuma
trois ans mon calendrier
j'ai vu que j'ai parti plein de projets
qui les gens sont pas ensemble
tout ce passe par part au fait que je
vis je viens espèces de fougères et
organismes parce que si j'ai organisé
mais à faire pour que les firmes
fonctionne sans moi mais je peux quand
même être sur la ferme
- tu es là parce que c'est là victor
choisi ouest il a toutes mes autres
projets je les adore son col mais ne
font pas que ça soit limitée une zone
tout le temps
cette semaine j'ai bloqué des cases
horaires les avant midi d après-midi
j'en ai quatre breaks dans le champ
parce que c'est quand même garder tout
ce monde-là plc pas disponibles à temps
dessus chez jean talon encore samedi
dimanche
heureusement j'ai ôté le pas dimanche
ça c'est sûr je vais faire un samedi sur
deux c'est l'autre chose qui est arrivé
c'est que moi j'ai travaillé comme un
fou pendant longtemps figé un peu
négligé ma vie familiale ma vie aussi je
faisais plus d'exercice beaucoup j'étais
vraiment absorbé par mes projets avec la
dalle à jean talon j'aime encore ça puis
j'aime se rencontrer les clients mais
tiges content des fois prendre le syndic
ma fille faire autre chose c'est fait
qu'une telle équilibre de tout ça mais
j'adore ça
si vous venez au marché je vous invite
si c'est vraiment le fun c'est les
produits sont bossi could mean shirt et
légumes qui compte 1 on s'arrose oui
j'ai mes passions avec l'écho vide
ouais ouais ces chiens-là métier si
j'avais le choix de paille ali n'était
pas juste le plexiglas et lé masque qui
s'était comme le bol contact qui
nourrissent et sont donc là mais l'homme
je pense qu'on recommence avec quelque
chose de nouveau on y le samedi on a nos
masques on n'a pas de plexiglas non un
plexiglas mais les gens peuvent quand
même quand nos légumes parce qu'avant on
était derrière eux choisissent et et
légumes puis j'ai une maison un peu ça
defeat de percussion mais lorsqu'on
ressent sortir et la matière parce que
oui merci infiniment c'était
réellement passé ce coup là extra merci
et à bientôt
merci d'avoir écouté ses podcasts
jusqu'à la fin j'espère que vous avez
apprécié la conversation ça prouve que
vous êtes de réelles fans de
conversation et du sans-fil pas de
casser on vous remercie vraiment
beaucoup
si vous voulez avoir plus de contenus
plus de conversations sur pétillante que
ça se passe il ya surper tués a non
seulement on met tous les podcasts en
ligne au moment où est ce qu'on les
tombes donc on a beaucoup de semaine
d'avant sur le pétrole mais on fait
aussi des encore moins de filtres qui
sont exclusifs au monde pète urnes
puisque on parle d'homme n'est que
l'émoi de la conversation qu'ont bien
d'avoir ce qu'on met un peu plus en
profondeur dans certains sujets qu'on
voulait aborder ou qu'on a abordé
pendant le podcast
donc allez sur notre page rituels et le
lien vers sa voix dans la description du
podcast qui remercie encore une fois de
nous avons écouté jusqu'à la fin